Wie hieß denn verdammt nochmal dieses Pigeon-Plugin damals, mit dem man das Chatfenster bereits geöffnet hat, wenn von dem Gegenüber diese Typing-Notifications bereits kamen?
Wir können es bald daran erinnern, das genutzt zu haben, aber keiner kommt auf den Namen.
Wie heißt denn das? Das war auch eine Star-Wars-Anspielung.
Irgendwas Force Rebe... Nee, keine Ahnung.
Egal. Aber wie gesagt, was ich gerne hätte, anstelle dessen, wäre die Idee genau umgedreht.
Nämlich hätte ich ein Chat-Plugin
oder was auch immer, was für ein Client
ich nutze, das mir
Nachrichten von anderen Personen rausfiltert,
solange die
noch nicht
dazu gekommen sind, das zu fragen
oder das zu sagen, was sie eigentlich sagen wollen.
Ich habe einen Kontakt, der schreibt generell
immer, hi. Und dann
öffnest du die Nachricht und dann sitzt du da
wartend, bis
er geschrieben hat, was er eigentlich
schreiben wollte.
Das ist so eine Verschwendung, wenn man
Er macht das mit Absicht. Ich hab den einmal drauf angesprochen.
Seitdem zieht er das konstant durch.
Gott, Ian, du Arsch.
Schönen Gruß an Ian an dieser Stelle.
Aber ich hab heute einen neuen coolen Messenger kennengelernt.
Und die Infrastruktur dafür ist erstaunlich einfach.
Das hast du mir erzählt.
Ah, ich weiß nicht, wie du dir denkst.
Mir ist es eigentlich gesagt, als du mir das erzählt hast,
wie Schuppen von den Augen gefallen.
Weil ich mir jedes Mal, wenn ich mir gedacht hab,
Also es geht erstmal zusammengefasst, es geht um
Talk. Das ist ein Kommandoteilentour,
mit dem man einfach mit anderen Benutzern auf der
gleichen Linux-Kiste schreiben kann,
auf der gleichen Unix-Kiste schreiben kann.
Und ich habe mir eigentlich schon vor Jahren gefragt, wenn ich mich auf
so einem Uni-Rechner eingeloggt habe
und da irgendwie mit Finger
nach anderen Benutzern gesucht habe
und du kannst dir auch anzeigen lassen, wer gerade online
ist.
Wie kann man die jetzt anschreiben? Das wäre cool, wenn es
das gäbe. Und aber
im Endeffekt gibt es das schon ewig. Ich wusste es bloß
nicht. Also Torque ist so ein Standard-Tunex-Tool,
habe ich aber auch erst letztens drüber gestolpert,
als ich nochmal mit
ein paar Freunden auf den
XCD gestoßen bin, wo die ganzen
Chat-Blasen für verschiedene Messenger, welche
Freunde nutzen, welche Systeme, welche Protokolle
und wo hast du da Übereinstimmung
und da sind unten in der Ecke zwei, einer hat
Wall-Unix
und einer Wall-Bathroom.
Das ist mein einziges Chat-Protokoll, mit dem man
die erreichen kann und da hatten wir mal
auf dem Uniserver die
Unix-Variante von Wall ausprobiert,
nicht die Werthang-Variante,
und haben da,
wie heißt das, Wall, Schreiben an der Wand,
oder ist das Way-All?
Also wenn du an der Klot-Wand schreibst
und dann halt die Nachricht für den
dahinter hast, das ist halt der Witz in dem XCD
gewesen.
Ich glaube aber gar nicht, ob Wall, Wall heißt,
weil an der Wand schreiben oder Way-All irgendwie.
Jedenfalls
haben wir das mal ausprobiert, nachdem wir
kurzzeitig auch gechattet haben über
die Apache-Logs voneinander.
wir haben quasi mit Curl
einfach Nachrichten
einander geschrieben an die jeweiligen Infrastrukturen
der anderen Person und aus den Serverlogs
rausgelesen, was die Nachbar
hat auch ein kurzes Skript gebaut
weil ich es sehr witzig fand, was
Chat to Apache dann direkt
aber was wir da gesehen haben
ist, dass auf dem Uniserver
Wall auch wunderbar funktioniert hat
das hat mich auch ehrlich gesagt kurz überrascht
Aber es schreibt auch wirklich alle an
Ja, du schreibst damit alle anderen Nutzer
die online sind gerade
Die online sind.
Die online sind, ja genau.
Es waren jetzt auch nur so 17 Leute oder so,
aber die haben alle die Nachricht bekommen,
die wir, also keine Ahnung,
ich weiß doch nicht genau, wie das funktioniert,
im Sinne von, ob das jemand anderen das einfach
in seine Session direkt reinschmeißt,
in die laufende TTY,
oder ob der das da, keine Ahnung,
aber nicht, dass wir, nee, keine Ahnung.
Das hätte bestimmt komische Effekte,
wenn du gerade sowas wie einen Hardtop auf hast.
Nee, war lustig und sind wir auch
auf den Talk gestoßen.
Da gibt es noch ein anderes Tool,
das war aber nicht auf der, oder war das Talk?
in irgendeinem anderen Tool gibt es auch noch was,
das sogar eine hübschere UI bietet,
ob das jetzt direkt Endcursus basiert war
oder nicht, weiß ich gerade gar nicht mehr,
war bei der Fehlfahl auf der Unimaschine nicht vorinstalliert,
deswegen haben wir es nicht ausprobiert,
aber da gibt es noch ein paar Dinge.
Finde ich cool, das war ein witzigeres
Messenger-Ersatz, aber klar.
Ja, wenn auf Arbeit auch so ein Build-Server wurde,
wenn du immer mehrere Leute
gleichzeitig eingeloggt haben kannst, das werde ich mal ausprobieren,
ob ich da drauf komme und dann,
also ob es da das Tool gibt.
Die Zeiten sind nie vorbei, wo auf Uniservern mehrere Leute
Zeit, die irgendwie FSH-Standard sind.
Heute laufen
auf einem Server 35 Docker-Container
und keiner miteinander reingeht.
Ich hab da meine alten NoPanic...
Die NoPanic, das ist so
die Zeitschrift hier in der TU Informatik.
Kriegst du als erstes in die Hand gedrückt,
vom FSH geschrieben, auf weißen Informationen.
Das hab ich meiner sehr alten NoPanic gelesen,
von wegen, wenn du wissen willst, wo andere Leute sind,
dann finger sie doch einfach.
Klar, die Zeiten sind leider vorbei.
Oh ja, da haben wir auch sehr viele
böse Witze schon drüber gehört.
Ich habe übrigens letztens auf Hacker News die History von Finger gelesen.
Warum heißt denn das jetzt Finger?
Die Idee kam daher, die ist nicht an den Sex-Joke irgendwie angelehnt, sondern der hat auch der Creator geschrieben.
Eben, das, wenn du Leute Finger hast.
Haha, haben viele Kinder darüber gelacht.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Jedenfalls meinte der Typ, der das geschrieben hat, dass die früher oftmals geschaut haben, wer wo ist und haben einfach den Output von...
Was gibt es da,
damit du siehst, welche User alle gerade online sind?
Finger. Nee, welche User online sind.
Who?
Es gibt W, das macht nochmal fast das Gleiche.
Es gibt auch noch Who im Ei,
das bin ich.
Who?
Probier mal ganz kurz.
Einfach Who?
Genau, genau.
Nee, er meinte,
Output von, wer gerade alles auf dem
Server online ist und da sind die Leute immer mit dem Finger auf dem
Display so runtergescrollt und haben gesagt, ah, das ist der
und das ist der und das ist der und
aus der Idee heraus hieß das zu dem Finger.
Ich dachte, das mit dem Finger hat
so eine Anspielung
wie Poken quasi.
Ich stupse dich an.
Nee, nee, also zumindest nicht ursprünglich.
Ich finger dich mal.
Wie hieß das bei StudiVorZ?
Boah, da fragst
mich was. Gruffeln oder
Grummeln oder? Gruffeln.
Ich war als Schüler-Fozet, bis Studi-Fozet habe ich es nie geschafft.
Das ist gestorben,
bevor ich studierte.
Es gab auch vor 10 Jahren schon
die schöne Webseite
Wann stirbt Studi-Fozet?
Was?
Das war eine der ersten
Da unten ist der Vorschlag.
Eine der ersten Single-Page
Single-Purpose-Pages,
die ich kannte.
Ah ne, die ist schon weg.
Kannst du jetzt Webarchive schauen?
Gibt's eigentlich, kann man sich auf
The Wayback Machine angucken, wie
die Wayback Machine vor 10 Jahren ausging?
So, Meta.
Das wäre mal witzig. Also du musst
ja eigentlich bloß, du nimmst diese URL jetzt
und schreibst nochmal Web Archive davor.
Gibt's hier eine
Rollsport-Taste?
Nee.
Das schneit Hendrik im Post alles raus.
Was? Ich schneid hier gar nicht.
Du kannst aber, wenn du vorhast zu husten oder zu niesen
oder irgendwas, kannst du mal kurz so machen
dann sind wir mal ganz kurz still
dann habe ich was zum Schneiden
und dann können wir uns bemühen
einfach hinterher den Satz, mit dem wir vorher angefangen haben
nochmal genau so zu sagen, das machen wir ab und zu machen
Ich wollte eigentlich meine Mate trinken
als Husten
Aber wir sind ja auch auf einzelnen Spuren
wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein Klicken oder sowas auf der Spur hast
dann kann ich das auch wegschneiden
Ich kann ja auch mal ganz leise Mate trinken
Das klappt wunderbar. Gestern auch prima geklappt.
Eben.
Ich höre nichts.
Aber du hörst uns schon auf den Dingern, oder?
Diese Folge wird übrigens gesponsert
von Clubmate.
Einen neuen Sponsor gefunden.
Krass.
Sektbronte.
Wusstest du, seit wann es Clubmate gibt?
Nein.
1924.
Okay, dann erzählt vom Krieg.
Haben bald ihr 100-jähriges.
Hießen aber erst in den 50ern Clubmate, davor Sektbronte.
Aber so ein Bild mit Adenauer
mit einer Club Marte in der Hand, wäre historisch
voll in Ordnung. Das Ganze
von der Brauerei Loscher? Ne, die haben
ich erst später gekauft. Das wurde irgendwie
dreimal, glaube ich, verkauft oder so
aber Loscher hat es heute in der Hand
damals noch nicht.
Wenn ich die Geschichte, dass die das auch jahrelang nie so richtig
wertschätzen wussten, dass die auch gesagt haben
ja, Marte könnt ihr gerne haben, aber
dass die halt jedes Mal noch rumgegangen sind und ihr
Bier, was sie eigentlich brauen, auch noch mitverkaufen
wollten, nehmt man auch unser Bier dazu
und das ist irgendwie keiner für interessiert.
24 ist schon krass
Was? Ach 1924?
Ja, ja
Du, 2024, weißt du schon, dann werden wir da
in Berlin stehen und raven
und hacken und feiern, dass es
100 Jahre Clubmatik gibt
100 Jahre Hackerkultur
In den goldenen Zwantigern
angefangen, die Ekrikultur.
Kilian, möchtest du mal das Willkommen sagen?
Ja, nee, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich sagen soll.
Das machst du. Das ist dein Ding.
Gut, dann fangen wir jetzt offiziell an.
Herzlich willkommen zu Akronomisierbar.
Heute mit
dem ersten wiederkehrenden Gast.
Jupp,
herzlich willkommen zurück.
Danke, aber ich will gar nicht die Lobby ernten.
Es gab ja noch den Steiger, der auch schon zweimal da war.
Der Steiger ist eigentlich offiziell mitmoderat.
Steiger ist kein Gast.
Im ersten Jahr hat er die Domain sogar mitbezahlt.
Tim, Leit, Fettnäpfchen.
Müssen wir rausschneiden.
Wir sind auch mit beiden Gästen.
Du bist wieder keiner Gast, Hendrik und ich sowieso.
Wir sind, ja.
Ja, eigentlich ist das ein Unmaintainter-Podcast.
Das ist nur zufällig hier,
wenn die Aufnahmen laufen.
Ab und zu sind wir mal selbst zu Gast.
Ja,
Jupp, du bist jetzt zum ersten Mal
wieder in der Stadt.
Das ist schön, dass du uns mal wieder besuchst.
Die Folge heißt jetzt offiziell Nack 2.0.
Wo wir diesmal alle trockenen Fußes hier sitzen.
Ich erinnere mich, das war ja schreckliches Wetter an dem Tag der Aufnahme von dieser Folge.
Ich auch immer, das war, keine Ahnung, nummeriert, glaube ich nicht im Kopf.
Ich glaube, es war die Folge 007.
Ja, und jetzt sind wir Folge 018.
018.
Ja, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass wir so lange durchhalten das Podcast,
aber irgendwie schaffen es doch immer wieder Leute,
wir müssen, aber irgendwie schaffen es doch
immer wieder Aufnahmen zu machen. Wir müssen einfach
immer weiter interessante Leute einladen.
Das hilft auf jeden Fall.
Ein paar Kandidaten hätte ich da noch so im Petto.
Ein, zwei haben sich sogar schon aktiv
angemeldet und gesagt, dass
ihr bei uns mal mitquatschen möchtet.
Das nehme ich jetzt nicht voraus, die Spannung.
Da müsst ihr uns schon abonniert behalten, das rauszufinden.
Aber ihr habt
auf jeden Fall eure Frequenz erhöht.
Das finde ich ganz angenehm.
Ja, jetzt war jetzt, wie gesagt,
mal wieder eine längere Zeit Pause,
weil ich umgezogen bin,
einen Monat lang oder sowas, aber
wir versuchen es jetzt heute wieder zu machen.
Jetzt haben wir ja auch ein professionelles Audio-Studio hier,
wo wir das machen können.
Das hilft bestimmt.
Die schallsichere Kabine
hat am längsten gedauert, aufzubauen.
Warum haben wir eigentlich nie in der Uni
aufgenommen, in diesem schallsicheren Dings da,
was im FAZ rumsteht?
Das können wir auch mal machen, aber
das spielt sich nicht mehr an.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen klaustrophobisch, oder?
Stimmt, das ist wirklich der arg auf der Pelle.
Und für Gäste ist überhaupt kein Platz für zwei Leute.
Dann würde ich es dann doch fast schon wieder am ASCII machen.
Ja, nee, ich glaube die ganz gut.
Es gibt auch an der TU Dresden,
an der Elektrotechnik-Fakultät,
gibt es zwei Räume.
Der eine ist ein scheiß schluckender Raum.
Da haben die so Spezial-Schaumstoff
und ganz angewinkelte Dinger.
Das ist ganz komisch, wenn man da drin ist.
Da hört man sich selber überhaupt nicht mehr.
Und die haben einen Raum, der ist so ähnlich wie das ASCII von der Akustik her.
Das ist nämlich der steil reflektierende Raum.
Da muss man sagen, der eine ist der scheiß spuckende Raum.
Genau.
Ich glaube, von erster Linie hat mir mein Opa mal erzählt.
Das war seine Fakultät, er ist ja noch Proffer, aber da hat man mich mal begeistert von dem Tipp, wie cool das sein soll.
Also das mit dem scheiß schluckenden Raum, das kann ich irgendwie ganz gut nachvollziehen,
damit man irgendwie keine Reflexion hat und irgendwie direkt die direkte Messung von den Geräuschen,
von irgendwelchen Sachen machen kann.
Aber wozu hast du denn der scheiß reflektierende Raum gedacht?
Was macht man damit?
Du hast die Akustiker der TU, die sitzen auch im Backhausenbau mit diesen Fakultänen Elektrotechnik.
Also sicherlich Gründe haben, dass man sowas...
Ja, dass Akustiker damit irgendwas machen, aber was macht man damit?
Eco-Cancellation testen.
Uh, interessant.
Ja, das klingt gut.
Also kann man auch zur langen Nacht der Wissenschaften, kommt man da rein.
Die ist ja jetzt in einer Woche, nee, in einem Monat, ziemlich genau.
Oder könnte man mal überlegen, ob wir da vielleicht eine Sonderfolge machen wollen?
Ich will den Lightning-Talk halten auf der LNDW über esoterische Programmiersport.
Stimmt, du hast ja neulich gesammelt sogar.
Hast du diesen Vortrag nicht sogar schon gehalten?
Nö. Aber das du gesammelt hast,
war irgendwie... Ja, ich hab bloß frühzeitig gesammelt,
damit ich mir ein bisschen Zeit hab, die Witzigsten rauszusuchen.
Aber dazu später mehr.
Möchtest du das jetzt nicht spoilen?
Nee, nee. Es gibt ja so eine Webseite, die heißt
esolangs.org
Das ist so eine Esolangs-Wiki, ja.
Das ist klasse. Und da hast du
meterweise esoterische Programmiersprachen.
Müssen die auch alle tatsächlich einen Compiler
haben oder reicht's, wenn man die irgendwie spezifiziert?
Also eine habe ich im Kopf, die heißt Sartre.
Da gibt es keine Referenzimplementation,
soweit ich weiß.
Das einzige Feature, was ich noch im Kopf habe, ist, dass du da
die Typen von Variablen oder die Werte von Variablen
nicht, also du setzt Variablen
nicht auf einen Wert, sondern du sagst, welchen Wert
sie nicht haben.
Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht,
dass es da eine Referenzimplementation gibt.
Das ist eine Theorie,
dass wie diese Sprache aussehen könnte.
Du musst ja einfach bloß den Wert dran schreiben
und ein logisches Nicht-Davortun.
Ja, aber wie baust du
da mit Nello World zusammen? Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, es gibt ja andere Sprachen
wie Mel Bogue, wo es Jahrzehnte gedauert hat,
bis jemand Nello World mal generiert hat.
Also ich habe
neulich
einen Podcast
entdeckt, der heißt
Functional Geekery.
Den hat mir der Marius empfohlen.
Grüße an Marius an dieser Stelle.
Und da ging es in der allerersten Folge
ging es direkt mit so einem Urgestein des Functional Programming los.
Und der Gaster hat da ein Buch empfohlen, das hieß
Structure and Interpretation of Computer Programs,
das auch aus den 60ern ist.
Und die interessante Zusammenfassung an der Stelle war,
dass eigentlich die größten Innovationen, was Programmiersprachen angeht,
alle in den 60er Jahren stattgefunden haben.
Alles, was wir heute an Sprachen cool finden,
Functionality, also Functional Programming,
imperatives Programming, objektorientierte Programmierung,
algebraische Datentypen,
alle solche Strukturen sind in den 50er, 60er Jahren
bereits in Programmiersprachen erfunden worden.
Und seitdem werden die eigentlich in anderen Sprachen
nur noch wieder hochgekocht und repetiert.
Und was der gesagt hatte, was eines von diesen Kapiteln,
was in diesem Buch interessant war,
war, dass die irgendwie die ersten 30, 40 Seiten
nur über
Functional Programming und
so Lambda-Kalkül-artige Sachen reden
und dann zum allerersten Mal
den Ist-Gleich-Operator einführen
und sich irgendwie auf eine halbe,
anderthalb Seiten lang dafür entschuldigen, dass sie jetzt
alles Schöne kaputt machen,
weil sie jetzt das Konzept von
Zuweisungen einführen,
was echt
eine Riesenverschlechterung
in der Programmierung ist.
Es ist ja auch so, dass die ganzen Konzepte aus der
Machine Learning Welt alle aus den 60er, 70er Jahren
kommen und man bloß halt keine Ressourcen
hatte, um die tatsächlich umzusetzen.
Man hatte keine Ressourcen und man hat irgendwie in den
90er Jahren dann irgendwann Machine Learning
irgendwie auch aufgegeben gehabt, weil man
keine saubere Implementierung hingekriegt hat und
das alles
nicht wirklich funktioniert hat und dann hat es
jahrelang kein Mensch angefasst, weil es ein totes
Thema war. Dann hat es erst vor
20 Jahren später.
Vor 10, 15 Jahren zum ersten Mal wieder Leute
interessiert und die haben es dann hingekriegt und
Punkt wieder. Aber es lag lange Zeit
brach.
Ich warte ja immer noch auf den großen
Mainstream-Durchbruch von funktionaler
Programme.
Irgendwann. Revelation.
Das machen halt Sprachen, die
nicht sagen, dass sie eigentlich
funktional sind.
Ja, so wie Rust.
Wir sind eine C++-Altern hier.
Pst, aber eigentlich ist das ein ML.
Eigentlich schreiben wir doch alle nur in ML-Derivaten
heute.
Ja, schön wär's.
Ja, außer du
in JavaScript.
Ja.
Was auch ein ziemlich krasses Jahr war
für Programmiersprachen, ist das Jahr 1995.
Ja,
das Jahr war für
Programmiersprachen. Genau, da wurden
nämlich so populäre Programmiersprachen wie
Java, JavaScript,
PHP und Ruby.
Das Jahr von PHP.
Alle in einem Jahr.
JavaScript und Java sind aus dem gleichen
Jahr? Ja. Krass.
dann ist ja Java relativ schnell
erfolgreich geworden.
Es war doch ursprünglich dafür gedacht,
dass man damit irgendwelche Setup-Boxen
programmiert hat.
Aber JavaScript hieß ja nicht von Anfang an direkt
JavaScript. Das hieß ja erstmal,
soweit ich weiß, auch die Ansatzzeit erstmal
ECMAScript, so wie es ja eigentlich heißt.
Nee, nee, CoffeeScript oder MokkaScript
oder sowas. Achso.
Und dann hat man sich gedacht, wir nennen es jetzt
JavaScript, weil Java ja so populär ist.
Genau, die Idee war einfach nur, wir nennen es jetzt JavaScript, weil
coole Dinge heißen Java.
Und weil wir auch geschweifte Klammern verwenden.
das sind solche Gemeinsamkeiten dieser Schrift.
Hast du nicht letztens gesagt,
mittlerweile sind die Sprachen
so ähnlich,
dass man da gar nicht mehr so die Differenz machen kann.
JavaScript hat
diverse OOP-Feature schon
ein bisschen mit drin, also modernes
JavaScript. Ich möchte fast behaupten, ich meine, ich habe mir
lange kein Java mehr angeguckt, aber TypeScript hat
ein cooleres Typ-System als Java.
Aber jetzt kriege ich
bestimmt Haue.
Glaubst du, die krassen Java-User,
die hören uns zu.
Was ich irgendwie festgestellt habe...
Hallo, liebe akronomisierbar
Hörer, die sich sehr gut mit Java auskennen...
Hallo Sascha.
Hi Sascha.
Von Sascha habe ich ja schon Hauer bekommen für genau diese Aussage.
Schreibt uns doch mal
und erklärt mir doch mal
bitte, dass das Typsystem von Java
eigentlich super geil ist.
Ich habe eigentlich keine Ahnung mehr von Java, wenn ich mich so genau
erinnere. Ich habe nur gehört, dass es
jetzt Lambdas gibt, die ganz gut zu benutzen sind.
Mit Java 8 kam da glaube ich was, oder?
Ja.
War noch nicht probiert.
Das ist alles, was ich weiß.
Was mir mal aufgefallen ist, dass alle Programmiersprachen
syntaktisch
mittlerweile an einem Punkt angekommen sind,
weil sie sich mittlerweile
alle aus den gleichen Töpfen bedienen.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch
die Heskel-Familie mit Idris,
was so ein bisschen aus dem
Welt der Weg ist.
Das ist keine große Familie.
Das ist keine große Familie, aber die meisten sind...
Es gibt die Lisbs und die Cs.
Und die Cs sind quasi
die Welt regieren, würde ich behaupten.
Grob gesehen.
Also C ist sowohl jetzt,
ob da jetzt Rust, Swift, Java,
JavaScript, alles was irgendwo
C ähnlich ist, mit drin liegt.
PHP, Ruby,
Python. Oh, war da Ruby.
Ruby ist von
1995, ja? Ja.
Und wann ist denn Python?
Oh, gute Frage.
Das macht ja nämlich zumindest jetzt ein
Kollege von mir, der bei mir mit im Büro sitzt,
Ruby nebenbei
dann kichert er manchmal so ein bisschen auf.
Also das Internet sagt, Python ist von 1991.
Das ist der Python, ist nämlich irgendwann
zwischen Ruby und Perl
entwickelt worden. Perl ist so von
87 oder 86 sogar.
Perl ist alt.
Also wenn es Ruby hat, witzige
Eigenschaften, und bei Ruby unterscheidet man ja,
da gibt es nicht nur Lambdas,
da gibt es Procs und Blöcke,
die sich subtil anders verhalten
und irgendwie andere Scoping-Eigenschaften haben.
Und man kann,
wie bei Swift irgendwie einen
Block an jede Funktion mit übergeben,
die dann...
Das kannst du in Swift aber nicht.
Nee, aber das sieht dann syntaktisch aus.
Achso, okay.
Und man kann...
Es gibt bei Ruby...
Ruby möchte ja so geschrieben werden, dass es
möglichst keine Überraschung gibt
und dass du eigentlich aber auch alles
einigermaßen menschlich lesbar schreiben kannst.
Es gibt ja nur 10 Aliase für jede Funktion.
Genau, es gibt irgendwie für jede Funktion 35
Aliases.
Es ist aber wirklich
philosophisch so gedacht, dass es
möglichst
the principle of least surprise
Es gibt dann allerdings trotzdem ein paar
übliche Überraschungen. Ich möchte an dieser Stelle auf den
Blog, kommt in die Shownotes,
Idiosyncratic Ruby verlinken
von einem
Unifreund von mir, Jan Lillis, der
den schreibt und ein großer Ruby-Hacker ist
mit schönen Seltsamheiten
von Ruby und zwei Sachen, die
auf die ich neulich
aufmerksam gemacht wurde von einem Kollegen.
Zum einen, es gibt logische Operatoren in Ruby,
und zwar und, und, oder, oder.
Als Strich und als M-Persend.
Und dann gibt es and und or.
Die verhalten sich anders.
Und die haben unterschiedliche Wichtungen.
Also du kannst den Satz schreiben.
Intuitiv auf jeden Fall.
Du kannst a und b oder c schreiben.
Und wenn du das mal mit den logischen Operatoren schreibst,
und wenn du das mit den Wörtern schreibst,
kommt ein anderer Ausdruck bei raus.
und du kannst Blöcke schreiben mit geschweiften Klammern
oder mit do
end und das
bindet auch, eins bindet
stärker als das andere.
Achso, ich dachte, das fällt dir exakt gleich.
Du kannst nämlich
einen Funktionsaufruf ohne Klammern machen
und einfach dahinter was aufrufen.
Da weißt du ja immer nicht, ob das, was ich aufrufe, ist das nur eine Variable,
die evaluiert, eine Variable, wo was drinsteht,
oder eine Funktion, die evaluiert wird.
Wenn du jetzt zwei Funktionen hast,
die eine heißt foo, die andere heißt bar
und in die eine, du schreibst den Foo
Bar und Bar
nimmt einen Block an und
Foo nimmt Bar
selber einen Block an.
Dann musst du bei dem
einen, und ich hab's mir natürlich nicht gemerkt,
bei dem einen musst du du End und bei dem anderen
musst du geschweifte Klammern nehmen, damit du das
richtig bindet, wenn du nicht
über den Klammern schreiben möchtest, weil du könntest ja auch einfach
Klammern schreiben, ist das klar.
Aber Ruby hat eigentlich ein paar schöne Eigenschaften.
Das ist ja so, dass Ruby alles ein Objekt ist.
Also auch die Zahl 7.
7 hat eine Funktion Times.
So ein Block.
Interessantes Konzept, ja.
Es ist sehr konsistent und sehr elegant.
Im Prinzip
finde ich Ruby auch echt schick als Sprache.
Einige, was mir in Ruby mal richtig hart abtürnt,
ist das Dependency Management System,
was meiner Meinung nach so broken beyond all
repairs ist.
Die haben immerhin das Log-File.
Immerhin das,
das muss man anrechnen, das stimmt.
Sehr viel kopiert heutzutage.
Das stimmt.
Was haben wir so an Themen für heute
überhaupt aufgeschrieben?
Oh, wollen wir mal anfangen, richtig über Themen zu reden?
Können wir mal machen.
Wir haben doch jetzt dich als Gast.
Du schlägst jetzt mal ein Thema vor.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich mal ein bisschen über den
XAI-Editor reden.
Das ist ein
Projekt, das hat
ein Google-Engineer,
Ralph Levine, als sein Freitagsprojekt
gestartet.
Das ist ein Editor,
der
so die Philosophie von
Wim und Emacs nimmt, aber das Ganze
immer auf eine moderne Plattform
umhebt.
Der ist auch in
Rust geschrieben.
Größtenteils.
Und der
wir werden noch einen Talk verlinken, glaube ich.
Hat auf jeden Fall
ein paar interessante Eigenschaften.
Der ist
Wie bist du überhaupt auf den Seidheter gekommen?
weil du das mal gehört hast oder benutzt du den selber?
Ich bin drauf gekommen,
weil ich den
Neura Station Podcast
höre und
da hat
der, der den rausbringt,
den Rav Levine mal eingeladen.
Was auf jeden Fall der, was
den Editor ausmacht, ist, der hat
Frontend und Backend getrennt.
Also es gibt
verschiedene Frontends für Betriebssysteme,
zum Beispiel, also das Populärste ist
das von macOS,
was in Swift geschrieben ist. Das hat ja auch der
Rave-Levin quasi als allererste selbst
mitgebaut. Genau, das ist so ein bisschen
das Paradebeispiel. Es gibt aber noch andere fürs Terminal.
Ich glaube für KDE gibt es eins.
Und das funktioniert im Prinzip auf die Art und Weise,
dass das Frontend quasi bloß ein
Renderer ist für den Text und
über so ein Message-Passing
System mit dem eigentlich
Editor spricht. Aber was
ist denn an so einem
Editor dann so schwer? Ich meine, im Endeffekt musst du doch dann
bloß einen langen String verwalten, wo der
ganze Text drin steht, oder? Was kann
man da alles falsch machen? Ja, es gibt
so interessante Probleme wie, was ist denn,
wenn der String nicht in deinen
Speicher passt, weil die Datei, die du anguckst,
64 GB groß ist.
Ja, aber das löst
doch mein Betriebssystem für mich schon, oder?
Das kommt drauf an,
was du für Algorithmen nimmst. Also es ist auf jeden Fall
irgendwann keine Option mehr, den ganzen
Stringen speichert zu halten.
Außerdem ist es
wohl erstaunlich schwer, was ich
auch nicht wusste, bei so
großen Dateien zu gucken, wo
Line-Endings sind
und Smooth
zu scrollen und
jammen und auch
wenn man den Text editiert,
dort Characters in der Mitte
einzufügen und
ohne gleich den Rest von dem Buffer immer wieder
zu kopieren und das hinten anzusetzen, was ja so
naiver Ansatz wäre. Und der
Ralph Levine, der hat da
Robes, das sind so
Datenstrukturen, die
es schon länger gibt, aber die ein bisschen schwierig zu implementieren
sind, genommen und
die in Rust implementiert. Also Robes
sind quasi andere Strings, oder?
Ja, das sind Strings,
die man so aneinander
kettet. Okay.
So eine P-Tree-artige
Datenstruktur, die es um
Strings darzustellen.
Was sehr interessant ist, oder was
Schwierig ist gerade zum Beispiel bei einem Source-Code-Editor,
ist, dass du
nicht nur den Text
roh als Text
erstellst, wie du es jetzt bei einem naiven
Notepad machen würdest, sondern
du hast ja ein Modell, du möchtest genau
Aussagen über jedes Wort,
über jedes einzelne Zeichen
in deiner Datei
haben. Du möchtest wissen, wenn ich
zum Beispiel ein Stück Source-Code aufmache,
dieses Wort ist ein Keyword,
das ist ein Variablen-Name, das muss ich so
einfärben, das muss ich so einfärben,
hier muss ich vielleicht zusätzlich was darstellen,
hier ist ein Fehler oder sowas, das muss ich unterkringeln
und das möchtest du halt, wenn
jemand was verändert und sich das plötzlich vielleicht,
was weiß ich, wenn ich eine Klammer hinzufüge, dann ist alles danach,
was danach kommt, hat plötzlich eine andere Bedeutung.
Oder wenn ich einen Anführungsstrich einfüge,
dann ist alles bis zum nächsten
Anführungsstrich hat eine komplett andere Bedeutung.
Das muss man irgendwie sauber abbilden, wenn du es einfach bloß
immer wieder frisch machen würdest oder
ab da hast du halt riesen
Rechenaufwand,
weil du jedes Mal deinen gesamten Text neu
verarbeiten musst.
Und das lösen jetzt Ropes auf eine elegante
Art und Weise, ja.
Ich glaube, die Ropes lösen
größtenteils das Problem des Einfügens von
Text in große Buffer.
Und das schnelle Rauslesen dann wiederum.
Das ist nicht mehr die
teuren Operationen sind, wenn du mittendrin
Dinge machen willst, okay.
Genau.
Was sie außerdem haben, ist ein sehr interessantes
Plug-in-Konzept. Und zwar
ist es so ein bisschen
gelöst wie bei der
Microservice-Architektur, dass du so
verschiedene
Services hast, zum Beispiel den Syntax-Highlighter,
der ist gar nicht in dem Core drin und der ist auch nicht
in der UI drin, die das dann anzeigt,
sondern der ist
ein extra Service, der
von außen Updates kriegt,
zum Beispiel wenn du scrollst,
kriegt er den neuen Text
und den kann er dann Syntax-Highlighten.
Und das Ganze passiert alles
asynchron. Du kannst
also weiter scrollen, während
Text syntax highlightet
und es wird dann einfach geupdatet.
Sie haben dann
auch Support für den
für das Language Server
Protokoll. Das ist das,
was
Microsoft erfunden hat
für den TypeScript Compiler,
um den dann mit
Visual Studio Code reden zu lassen.
Das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich schönes Konzept,
um es mal ganz kurz zusammenzufassen.
Das Language
Server Protokoll nimmt quasi den
Compiler, also wenn es bei TypeScript...
Oder irgendeine Toolchain, muss ja nicht die Compiler
unbedingt machen. Im Endeffekt, früher war ein
Compiler einfach was, da hast du
Quelltext reingeschmissen und der hat dir
Compilat rausgeschmissen.
Ah, das ist dieses Wort.
Das sagst du mit Absicht.
Aber eigentlich hat ja so
ein Compiler oder alles, was
in einem Compiler dazugehört, das ganze Tooling
rundherum, hat da extrem viel Wissen über den Text.
Und was man mit
dem Language Service anfängt, ist, dass man
den Compiler mit seinem Wissen
über den Quelltext noch andere
Funktionalitäten durchführen lässt. Also
bei TypeScript liest man da
immer in den Release Notes relativ
interessante Sachen. Jetzt bei 2.8 ist
dazugekommen, dass der Compiler
in der Lage ist, deine Imports neu zu
sortieren. Das ist ein Feature, was der Compiler anbietet.
Das sagt dann einfach der
Editor über das Protokoll
hier Compiler, du hast diese Funktionalität,
mach das mal und
der löst das dann direkt
und spricht asynchron mit dem
Compiler und kriegt den Worten zurück.
was ziemlich cool ist. Das ist halt bei C++
und anderen Sachen fehlt. Da gibt es zwar einen Compiler,
aber das gesamte
so Refactoring-Funktionalität
und so weiter und so fort, da haben wir die meisten
IDEs nochmal selber
gebaut. Syntax-Highlighting könnte man
eigentlich auch den Compiler machen. Das muss ja wie gesagt nicht
der Compiler tun. Der Compiler hat zwar das Wissen, wie man
den AST aufdrüsselt und
was was ist, aber das kann ja auch
externes Tooling lösen, was dann diesen
Language Service bereitstellt,
mit dem du interagieren kannst. Ja, aber es
Es gibt zum Beispiel extrem viele Anwendungen,
die zum Beispiel nochmal einen C++
Parsern selber gebaut haben oder
den Ast
nochmal komplett aufbauen. Das ist ja das, wovon
so Firmen wie JetBrains leben,
dass sie quasi in der Lage sind,
Aussagen über C++ zu treffen und dann das
zu durchsuchen. Genau, aber das hat halt
noch gewisse Nachteile, weil
wenn es dann wirklich zwei verschiedene Implementierungen
sind, die dann den Source-Map passen,
dann können die divagieren. Also ein Beispiel,
was mir einfällt, ist Visual Studio,
also nicht Visual Studio Code,
sondern das normale Visual Studio.
Die haben einen eigenen C++-Compiler,
der nur sowas wie Find Reference oder Syntax-Highlighting
und solche Sachen macht.
Also IntelliSense ist auch dieser komische Intel-Compiler,
den sie da noch immer extra für drin haben.
IntelliSense ist nochmal ein weiterer zusätzlicher Compiler
von JetBrains, den man als Plugin...
Von JetBrains? Okay.
Und man hat dann...
Also ich habe schon öfter mal die Situation gehabt,
dass der richtige Compiler
das so kompiliert hat, aber dass
der Compiler,
der dann mir find by reference
machen sollte, den Source-Code
nicht parsen konnte,
sodass ich dann keinen find by reference
im Projekt hatte.
Es gibt jetzt bei C++
gibt es ClangD.
Das ist
eine Implementierung in einer Clang-Codebase,
die auch das Language-Server-Protokoll
spricht. Und da hat
Apple letzte Woche verkündet,
dass sie Xcode
darauf umstellen und
dass sie jetzt ganz viel darauf
kontributen wollen, um ihr
eigenes Tooling, was in Xcode
solche Sachen macht, nicht mehr zu
benutzen und dafür ganz viel zu knicken, die zu
kontributen.
Und dann Language Server Protokoll sprechen.
Genau, die sprechen dann Language Server Protokoll.
Oh, das wäre herrlich. Das wäre super schön,
wenn Xcode das könnte.
Aber nur für C++ leider.
Weil sie ja
Sourcekit für den Rest haben.
Genau.
Obwohl das abgefahren ist, wir waren ja gerade
beim
Zy-Editor.
Im Endeffekt, was abgefahren ist,
dass es einfach bloß ein IPC-Protokoll
ist, wo sich zwei
Prozesse irgendwie JSON-Nachrichten
in uns erschicken. Ja, sehr viele. Also wie gesagt,
es gibt halt welche für
Syntax-Highlighting, es gibt welche
für diese Refactoring-Sachen.
Man könnte sich auch
noch mehrere andere ausdenken.
Und es ist dann alles
in so einem Ökosystem und spricht alles JSON miteinander.
das Problem, was man dabei aber hat, ist
wenn der eine
Prozess
meinetwegen Codeformatierung macht
und du gleichzeitig tippst, dann kannst du
Konflikte haben
weil das auch alles asynchron
und nicht blockierend funktioniert, gibt es
dieses Problem, und das haben sie durch auch eine sehr interessante
Datenstruktur
gelöst, und zwar
CRDTs
das sind Conflict-Free
Replicated Data Types
und das ist eine
Art und Weise
auf Datentypen
Transformationen zu formulieren,
für die es immer
eine Auflösung, immer eine konfliktfreie Lösung gibt.
Klingt spannend.
Funktioniert das?
Ja, das funktioniert.
Es ist mathematisch
bewiesen, dass es funktioniert.
Wie funktioniert das? Sind das so eine Art Monade,
die dann irgendwie die
einzelnen Operationen erstmal
cachen und dann irgendwann
linearisieren und ausführen?
oder hast du da ein bisschen Einblick rein,
wie die Dinger funktionieren?
Ich habe mal die Paper gelesen
und ich habe es auch mal verstanden.
Aber es ist halt nicht was,
was man jeden Tag braucht.
Vielleicht können wir diese Papers
ja mit in die Show Notes tun
für die ganz harten Zuhörer.
Also die Idee dabei ist,
dass du ein Set von Operationen hast
und ein Set von Reihenfolgen
und dass du halt immer,
dass du halt für deinen Datentyp,
für alle Transformationen definierst,
was passiert, wenn zwei
davon sich überkreuzen.
Also eine ganz einfache Lösung dafür wäre,
was sind Zufügen und eine Sortierfunktion?
Ihr habt eine
Lampe, da könnt ihr
die Farbe ändern und Kilian
kann die Farbe ändern und Hendrik kann die Farbe ändern
und eine einfache Lösung des Problems
wäre, Kilian gewinnt immer,
wenn es einen Konflikt gibt.
Das ist sehr einfach, ja.
Das ist sehr einfach,
Das ist natürlich praktisch nicht wirklich hilfreich,
zumindest nicht für den Fall vom XAI-Editor.
Aber
es ist halt eine Art und Weise, wie man gut parallel
editieren kann.
Das ist gar nicht so abwegig, wenn man sagt,
wenn der Nutzer tippt, dann ist immer der Nutzer-Input
das valide und nicht, dass irgendwie das Formatting
dazwischen kommt, den Nutzer-Input wieder wegwirft.
Ja, jetzt bei Code,
bei Source-Code ist es ja, kann man ja vielleicht noch
die Lösung finden, dass zum Beispiel Code-Formatting
schreibt ja eigentlich an dem Code selber
nichts um, sondern es fügt nur an
stellen Leerzeichen
und Zeilenumbrüche hinzu.
Ja, möglicherweise macht das auch Groß- und Kleinschreibung
anders oder vielleicht benennt
es sogar Dinge um.
Also könnte ja denkbar sein.
Wenn dein Model im Hintergrund der AST
von der Sprache ist, dann kannst du
dann trotzdem auf dem Ding weiterhin
noch zum Beispiel Syntax-Highlighting machen
oder Find-by-Reference
machen, weil das eigentliche Objekt
hat ja zwar einen anderen Namen, aber es ist immer noch
genau das gleiche Objekt. Also die haben es auf eine Art und Weise
gelöst, wie es einfach für Text funktioniert.
dann ist es natürlich noch besser
und es gibt auch, also wenn ihr mal auf GitHub guckt, gibt es auch so eine Singer wie
Live-Editoren
die mit sowas geschrieben sind, wo dann 20 Leute
live editieren können und es funktioniert auch
interessant
ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt den
Seiditor schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr angeguckt
ich habe mir immer mal installiert
und mir dann vorgenommen, damit besonders große Dateien
wenn ich die
wenn ich die mal durchscrollen wollte, so
generierte, konkatenierte
Webpack-Ausgaben
um welche 20.000 Zeilen
JavaScript-Dateien. Der hat ja quasi schon einen Syntax-Highlighter
dabei und ich habe dann da drin rumgescrollt
und war dann trotzdem enttäuscht, dass wenn ich irgendwie
ganz schnell gescrollt habe, dass der dann
erst nachträglich,
nachdem ich irgendwo an der Stelle angekommen bin,
mit Highlighten und tatsächlich
Render noch hinterhergekommen ist, aber weil er halt
der View, der tatsächliche Editor
auch wirklich immer bloß den Teil
im Cache hat, der gerade im Feld
sichtbar ist. Genau, also es ist sogar so,
dass der
Teil, der angezeigt wird, wird auch über
JSON-APC übertragen.
Es gibt ja
momentan noch andere
Editoren, die sich relativ schnell entwickeln
und ein bisschen gegeneinander kämpfen,
weil du gerade gesagt hast,
das ist
ein performanter in Rust geschriebener Editor,
was eigentlich von der Performance
mich ehrlich gesagt auch überrascht
ist tatsächlich Visual Studio Code,
weil man da relativ smooth
in langen Quelltextdateien hin und her scrollen kann
und das einfach super funktioniert.
Bei einer richtig langen Dateien wirft das Ding auch die Arme hoch,
weil es einfach nicht in der Hand reinkriegt.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel, wenn ich in Vim schnell in einer langen Datei scrolle,
dann bin ich manchmal irgendwo angekommen
und sehe dann, dass es nachträglich erst geheiligt wird zum Beispiel.
Das überrascht mich,
dass Vim da als Renderer schlechter performt.
Vergleich mal Sublime und VS Code.
Sublime rennt immer noch weg.
Sublime ist immer noch ziemlich schnell, aber was mir jetzt gerade noch
als Beispiel einfällt, ist X-Ray.
Stimmt, das gab es ja auch mal.
Und zwar arbeiten die Leute von Atom daran,
ihr Textrendering.
Hab ich dir jetzt was vorbeggenommen?
Das ist okay, ich wollte nur
noch die Hörer warnen,
wenn sie jetzt ganz schnell
auf die GitHub-Seite von XyEditor
gehen und den dann sofort benutzen wollen,
ist es immer noch im Alpha-Statum.
Sie haben
dass Newlines umgebrochen werden
aber Syntax-Highlighting
geht noch nicht so richtig und es ist
mehr noch ein Proof-of-Concept und sie probieren
das Backend und die ganzen APIs
vernünftig hinzukriegen und es ist
noch nicht in einem Zustand
dass Leute das benutzen können
die nicht an einem Editor rumhacken wollen
Aber Syntax-Highlighting für Rust geht
Achso, okay, das ist so dann
Und zwar gibt es
gibt es einen
den Namen suche ich mal noch raus
für die Shownotes,
der dieses, aber das finde ich vielleicht
live raus.
Das ist jetzt die Magic des Schneidens.
Und zwar gibt es Tristan Hume,
der hat
Syntect gebaut und das hatte ich vielleicht auch
schon mal als Star vor einiger Zeit, beziehungsweise
ich habe es bestimmt vor zwei, drei Folgen erwähnt, als ich erzählt hatte,
dass ich in San Francisco war. Der hat nämlich
auf dem
Bay Area Rust
Meetup einen Vortrag gehalten an dem Abend,
als ich da war. Der hat
Syntect gebaut, das ist quasi ein
Syntax-Highlighter
in Rust und als
Beispielanwendung hat er SynCut gebaut,
damit kann man
geheiligteten
Text einfach cutten
und der
passt dazu die Syntax-Highlighting-Dateien
von Sublime.
Er hat
auch Messungen gemacht
und hat gemeint, er ist damit einer der
schnellsten Syntax-Highlighter überhaupt, aber
an manchen Stellen, aus technischen
Gründen, ist trotzdem Sublime
immer noch wesentlich schneller im Syntax-Highlighten.
Das ist eigentlich krass. Wenn du mal drüber nachdenkst, was Sublime
eigentlich für technisches,
also engineeringmäßig,
was das für eine Qualität hat, ist schon ziemlich krass.
Da ist da ein Typ dahintersteckt, der das Ding schreibt.
Aber zwei mittlerweile, glaube ich.
Dieses Ding
powert, glaube ich, mittlerweile das Syntax-Highlighting von
Zy. Der hat nämlich ein
Praktikum,
ich glaube, entweder bei Google gemacht oder
hat auch wie ein Internship bei Mozilla und arbeitet
mit Ray Flevin zusammen, die waren nämlich
beide an dem Abend da.
Es ist auch ehrlich,
ehrlich gesagt, immer wieder erstaunlich,
wie schwierig
technisch es ist, einen vernünftigen Editor
zu schreiben. Man denkt, das klingt
so trivial, das ist ja
gar nichts, gerade in so einem
einfachen Zilla-Editor, da steckt auch überhaupt nichts drin,
Logik, aber ja, das ist ja eben
ein immenses Unterfangen.
Es ist halt mehr als nur, welche Tasten
Kombinationen verwende ich zum Schluss,
E-Max oder VR-Moders.
Auch diese Obsession, mit der die Leute
da rangehen in diesen
XAI-Editor-Talk von Riff Levin,
da erzählt er auch, dass sie so eine
Testumgebung haben, wo sie
eine Kamera
mit Lichtsensor an
einen Arduino gekoppelt
gebaut haben, um zu messen,
wie lange es dauert, wenn man
eine Taste drückt, bis der Charakter
auf dem Bildschirm erscheint und dass sie daran
ganz optimiert mit
verschiedenen OpenGL
Earning-Strategien für die Grafikkarte,
für das macOS Frontend und Vulkan
und alle möglichen Sachen
und sie
hat sich noch Möglichkeiten ausgedacht, wie sie
nochmal hundertmal schneller sind als das Apple
Frontendering, was in OS X drin ist.
Also es sind halt wirklich
Leute, die das obsessiv betreiben.
Das finde ich großartig. Gerade an der Stelle muss man
ansetzen. Ich auch, das ist auch so eine richtig schöne
Nerd-Disziplin, weil
man kann es selber benutzen und es ist
technisch schwierig und
ganz übertreiben.
Das menschliche Auge ist ja für sowas eigentlich enorm
tolerant. Wenn ich jetzt
ein Musikvideo gucke und
das Video und das
Audio ist bis zu
eine Drittelsekunde auseinander, dann
optimiert mein Gehirn diesen Unterschied
weg. Aber danach wird es unanschaubar.
Und im gewissen Punkt ist es schlimm,
aber dadurch, dass die Schallgeschwindigkeit so
viel langsamer ist als die Lichtgeschwindigkeit und wir
teilweise Sachen in mehreren hundert Metern
Entfernungen wahrnehmen, deren Geräusche
erst später bei uns
ankommen, ist unser Gehirn eigentlich relativ
gut gewohnt, solche
gleichmäßigen Delays
auszucanceln.
Aber nicht bei Programmiereditoren.
Also ich bin ja
E-Mails-Nutzer und
ich habe lange Zeit immer mal wieder
ab und zu mal probiert, so IDEs
zu benutzen.
Und ich bin immer
an zwei Sachen gescheitert. Erstmal waren
sie mir zu langsam, sie haben sich wirklich zu
das Delay war mir zu hoch.
Ein minimaler Lack und man spürt das schon.
Das fühlt sich einfach sluggisch an.
Und das Zweite war, dass ihr einfach nicht gut Text bearbeiten könnt.
Das stimmt.
Aber du wolltest eigentlich
was über X-Ray, einen anderen
Editor erzählen. Ja, genau, im Endeffekt.
Also dieses Problem, dass Performance wichtig ist,
merken gerade die Leute, die Editoren
in Elektron bauen.
Zum Beispiel Atom. Ich weiß nicht, ob das
Atom jetzt nicht mittlerweile von
Visual Studio Code komplett der Rang abgelaufen
Die laufen immer noch recht stark, aber irgendwie nutzen die, also die haben ihre Userbase, aber die Leute sehen ein, dass das VS Code einfach besser performt, wenn man schon einen von diesen beiden Editoren nutzen möchte.
Und beide haben ihr Rendering-Backend genauso wie XI eigentlich jetzt nicht mehr, schon längst nicht mehr in JavaScript, wo man sagen würde, ich rendere meinen Source-Code, wie ich das mit Highlight.js oder so machen würde, in HTML und CSS, sondern die haben eigentlich beide mittlerweile native Rendering-Sachen im Hintergrund und pasten den Output davon eigentlich nur noch in den Canvas rein, weshalb die relativ gut performen.
Aber das Rendering wird ja sowieso von Blink der Chromes-Blog-Rendering-Engine gemacht.
Das ist ja schon nativ.
Ja, das ja, aber es geht halt noch schneller mit etwas Optimiertem.
Also zum Beispiel das Terminal von VS Code ist nicht viel langsamer als das im Rendering,
als zum Beispiel Alacrity.
Es ist deutlich schneller als zum Beispiel iTerm 2.
iTerm 2 ist verdammt zügig unterwegs.
Nee, Quatsch, ich bewechsel gerade.
Apples Terminal war super schnell
im Vergleich zu vielen anderen.
Und die haben halt in einer Version von etwas,
was man wie in Elektron
bauen würde, halt mit HTML und JavaScript,
umgebaut auf irgendwas natives,
was einfach in ein Canvas reinbrennt.
Und da
ein Shared Memory System.
Und das macht es einfach extrem viel schneller,
weil die wahrscheinlich direkt
aus WebGL raus oder so.
Jetzt bewege ich mich natürlich
wieder auf Glatteis, aber wenn man sich
Anschlux von VS Code anguckt, da
gab es von der einen Version noch den nächsten
extremen Performance-Sprung.
Mein Indikator dafür
ist immer diese schöne Anwendung C-Matrix.
Kennt ihr
C-Matrix?
Das ist ein
Out-of-Order-Github-Star.
C-Matrix
ist eine...
Warte, ich mach's mal
bloß für euch an und ihr könnt da mal
reagieren. Das ist einfach so ein
Matrixcode. Ja, okay.
Das ist einen in Endcursor.
Oh Gott, wie es einbricht.
Und sobald du natürlich ein großes Terminal hast,
das ist jetzt hier,
ich kann jetzt hier noch
Bolt anmachen.
Das geht, glaube ich, so. Und dann kann ich
noch die Geschwindigkeit, also mit A mache ich dann,
dass diese Zeilen asynchron voneinander laufen.
Und da siehst du schon, das ist
Wart, das mal im macOS-Terminal.
Also, liebe Hörer, ihr seht jetzt hier
gerade so eine, stellt euch vor,
ihr seht die Matrix-Animation,
wo die Schriftzeichen runterlaufen
und es hat so gefühlt 5 Frames.
Genau, das ist jetzt hier nicht viel besser,
ehrlich gesagt.
Hast du in iTerm mal den
GPU-Mode ausprobiert?
Dann läuft das komplett auf der GPU, die Rendering,
ähnlich wie Alacrity das macht.
Und jetzt mache ich mal daneben
Alacrity auf
und das muss ich natürlich jetzt hier
auch mal groß machen.
Das ist jetzt natürlich blöd, weil die Schrift
ich kann die Schrift nicht live
kleiner machen, aber
es hat jetzt einen leichten Vorteil dadurch, dass es
aber immer das ist
bedeutend flotter.
Ja, das Ding ist
Cheaten.
Aber dafür können die nicht scrollen.
Die können halt immer nur an einem Punkt ein Zeichen
darstellen und die Zeichen kommen halt
wiederholen sich ja auch
ständig dementsprechend.
Ich würde mich auch interessieren, wie ITerms
GPO-Mode damit zurechtkommt.
Das kann irgendwie in den Warnsettings
gibt es da
Metal vielleicht?
Wie ist das denn?
Zumindest wenn ich diese gleiche Anwendung
in dem Terminal von Visual Studio Code
aufmache, ist das schon...
Wenn ich das zu groß mache, ist das eigentlich
standard so gut.
Benutzt ihr denn Electricity im Alltag?
Kann man das schon benutzen?
Ich habe es mal eine Zeit lang benutzt für Sachen
wenn ich zum Beispiel
schnell irgendwas cutten möchte,
wo viel durchläuft, aber eigentlich selber nicht.
Es ist halt
wirklich ein bloß Terminal,
sagen wir, Renderer.
Alles, was man so an Convenience Features drumrum braucht.
Du musst es halt mit T-Mux nutzen.
Scrollback alleine
kann es halt auch überhaupt nicht. Das ist so ein
Branch, der mich schon seit Monaten auf GitHub
folge und da passiert einfach
überhaupt nichts. Das ist leider ein bisschen schade.
Aber es ist performance-mäßig super.
Das ist allerdings nicht das, was man
meistens braucht. Benutzt du das mit TMAX?
Ich habe es mal versucht eine Zeit lang.
Ich renne mit TMAX aber immer in die Probleme rein,
dass ich nicht glücklich werde mit
Text Selection. Das ist mir einfach
ein zu großer Krampf und ich habe mich
zu sehr gewöhnt an die
nativen Pains und Tabs von iTerm,
die einfach das selbe machen,
genauso schön über Keyboard-Shortcuts zu steuern
sind und im Zweifelsfall
Text Selection prima unterstützen,
so wie ich für das System gewohnt bin.
Aber so Text Selection ganz normal geht?
Das geht schon.
ja, aber halt über Zeilen hinweg, wenn du mehrere
Paints nebeneinander hast, ist es halt immer broken.
Also das ist
das eine Problem, was ich halt mit T-Max
schon länger habe, vor allem unter Mac OS, weil ich da einfach
keine saubere Lösung für finde.
Also eine Lösung, die ich immer nehme, ist Option-Command
markieren.
Dann kann man
eine Box markieren.
Also wenn man
zwei T-Max-Paints hat nebeneinander
und jetzt hier was rauskopieren will, dann
ähm
achso, ja, meine Option-Taste
ist kaputt, das kann man nicht.
Schönes, dass du hast, oder übrigens?
Interessant, das ist vielleicht publisch nochmal aus.
Bist du eigentlich
zufrieden mit der Tastatur von deinem
MacBook? Ich hab da
vorhin einen kleinen Hint gegeben.
Genau, wollen wir jetzt wirklich
gleich das Thema wechseln? Ach, warum nicht?
Es sei denn, du hast zu sein
noch irgendwas, dann können wir auch gerne noch was zu beschwingen.
Ich wollte nur sagen, das X-Ray
ist der Nachfolger von Atom,
wo man... Also nicht von Atom selber,
aber von dem
Der Text-Editor
in Atom. Genau, von dem Editor
bei Editor-Model.
Da ist auch relativ viel in Rust geschrieben
und der nimmt auch CRDTs
um Konflikte aufzulösen,
aber diesmal nicht für
die von mehreren Services,
sondern die von mehreren Leuten.
Also es ist ein Editor, der dafür gebaut ist,
dass mehrere Leute gleichzeitig
an einem Stücks Hauscode editieren können.
So ähnlich wie in Google Docs.
Sowohl wie es Code als auch Atom hatten ja vor kurzem
so ein Plugin rausgebracht, wo man direkt so in einer
Editor-Session quasi, die du sharen kannst
zu einer anderen Editor-Instanz von dem selben
Editor, um da
keine Ahnung, Pair-Programming zu machen oder
was weiß ich, jemandem das zu zeigen oder
um keine Ahnung, Etherpad zu faken,
was man auch so machen möchte.
Das ist, glaube ich, bei beiden seitdem auch nicht mehr viel passiert.
Ich wollte das auch nicht, weil ich da für mich
persönlich überhaupt keinen Use-Case für habe, aber
warum nicht, klar.
Also ein schöner Use-Case wäre, wenn du zum Beispiel eine Code-Base
hast, die bei dir in einer Firma
ist und du kennst dich mit einem Projekt, mit einem
nicht wirklich gut aus und dann
rufst du einfach bei den Kollegen an
und ihr macht direkt eine Pair-Programming-Session
auf dem Ding auch zusammen.
Ich finde auch so beim Pair-Programming selber wäre das manchmal vielleicht auch ganz cool,
weil es gibt ja immer so langweilige
Phasen, wo so
sich beide einig sind, okay, das
muss man jetzt mal in der extra Methode refactoren.
Sehr cool, wenn in demselben
Dokument der andere, der
gerade dem Refactoren dann nur zugucken
würde, wenn der dann schon mal
was anderes machen kann oder dass man sagen kann, der Block
und der Block, die müssen beide
refactored werden. Jetzt machen wir mal den einen
ich und den anderen. Du tippst hier oben,
ich hacke da unten.
Die paralysierbaren Tasks direkt aufsplitten auf die
Workers-Leute.
Das ist etwas,
was mir bei T-Mux komplett fehlt, weil ich
manchmal irgendwie, du machst eine Session auf,
beide loggen sich auf einer SSH-Session ein,
du machst ein T-Mux auf, aber im Endeffekt hast du
nur einen Cursor, du kannst nicht mal,
es können nicht mal zwei Leute, zwei unterschiedliche
Paints auswählen.
Doch, das geht.
Das geht. Das wurde mich überhaupt nicht, dass das irgendwie geht.
Ich dachte, das geht gerade nicht.
Aber das können wir gerne auch nochmal ausprobieren.
Aber eigentlich wollte ich ja über meine Tastatur ranten.
Das ist ein hübsches, schönes neues MacBook mit dieser sehr schönen, flachen Tastatur.
Also neu im Sinne von anderthalb Jahre alt.
Aber die aktuellste Generation.
Die aktuellste Generation, zumindest optisch von außen.
Genau, und es ist ja schon bekannt, dass die Tastatur mehreren Leuten anstößt.
Es hat angefangen damals, dass die physisch nichts mehr anstößt.
Also ich finde allein diese extrem kurzen Anschlagwege, finde ich recht unbefriedig.
Ich finde das toll.
Also ich liebe diese Tastatur vom Gefühl her, muss ich sagen.
Genau, also Apple war ja sowieso schon immer Vorreiter darin, Tastaturen dünner zu machen.
zu den alten ThinkPad-Zeiten,
wo es noch
Tastaturen mit richtig Hub in Notebooks gab,
da hat ja Apple schon angefangen,
diese Tastaturen mit den
quadratischen Tasten,
die so einen Abstand
zwischeneinander haben, zu bauen.
Die so abgerundet leicht waren?
Genau. Ich hatte 2009
so ein MacBook, so ein schwarzes MacBook,
wo das das erste Mal
gesehen hat.
Stimmt, da hatten die aber schon die flachen
auf der nicht mehr ganz aktuellen
silbernen Generationen noch mit drauf sind,
die Hendrik und ich ja da haben.
Das war ja schon relativ ähnlich zu dem.
Waren das schon so Chiclet-Tastaturen?
Noch nicht ganz, aber die
gingen schon auf jeden Fall in die Richtung.
Da gab es ja nochmal so auf den alten,
waren das die Halo-Macbooks, die auch das Laufwerk
vorne noch mit drin hatten, die hatten so
leicht abgerundete Tastaturen.
Also abgärts so eine schräge Anerkennung.
Genau, genau, genau.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie dieses Prinzip
ja jetzt nochmal auf die Höhe getrieben
mit der aktuellen MacBook Pro-Generation.
und da haben sie sich,
also viele Leute haben sich ja
beschwert darüber, dass die Wege
zu kurz sind, also der Hendrik zum Beispiel gerade.
Ich habe deswegen extra das
Gerät nicht geholt. Das finde ich jetzt persönlich
gar nicht so schlimm, weil die haben... Das ist geil, das fühlt sich einfach
geiler auf dem zu tippen, das ist so, das Gefühl
und vor allem das Geräusch finde ich richtig sexy.
Ich finde es auch sehr eingenehm, dass sie so
einen ganz, dass sie so
einen ganz definierten, ganz definierten
Druckpunkt haben,
der auch ganz stark dann abfällt. Also man
man muss relativ doll drücken und dann geht es ganz schnell runter
also ich finde, das fand ich am Anfang
gar nicht schlecht, aber es stellt sich nun heraus, dass
die Tastatur an sich halt
ein bisschen unpraktisch ist, in dem Sinne
dass wenn man da mal ein kleines Staubkorn
drunter kriegt unter eine Taste
dann funktioniert
die nicht mehr, muss man ganz doll
drauf drücken, dass sie funktioniert
da gibt es so ein YouTube-Video
I'm pressing the spacebar
verlinke ich mal
Genau, also ich habe jetzt so im Wochenabstand, dass ich irgendwie mir eine Luftsprühdose suchen muss, von allen Seiten die Taste mal so besprühen oder vielleicht mit einem kleinen Messer so ein bisschen anheben und dann da drunter sprühen muss.
Das kann es aber auch nicht sein.
Ich habe, glaube ich, in der Pair-Programming-Session, als du mal bei mir am Tisch saß, einen schönen Hack gefunden, wie man die Tasten gut abbekommt.
Also wenn ihr selber diese Tastatur habt und die nicht irgendwie raushebeln wollt, weil man damit auch die Chignets gerne mal kaputt macht,
man muss sie eigentlich möglichst gerade abziehen und dafür eignet sich besonders gut Patafix.
Patafix, ja.
Also genau, die nächste Eskalationsstufe, wenn das Sprühen nicht hilft und das Pusten und das Sprühen und das Schütteln nicht hilft, ist dann die Taste wirklich auszubauen.
Das muss man sehr vorsichtig sein.
Ich habe jetzt auch schon
bei einigen diese kleinen Stifte,
die da dran sind, die Plastikstifte abgebrochen,
die da dran sind.
Die sind nicht aus einem
massiven Stück Aluminium gefräst?
Die Tastatur ist Teil des
Unipollys. Das ist alles Plastik
und nicht unbedingt von besserer Qualität.
Aber
letzte Woche habe ich jetzt wirklich noch so
einen neuen Fehlermodus entdeckt, den ich
noch nie hatte. Und zwar
meine Option-Taste,
die fällt raus.
Nein, oh Gott, du hast sie nur schräg angetippt
und plötzlich war sie weg.
Also ich drehe mal und es ist vor allen Dingen gar nicht,
also ich habe mein Notebook irgendwie zugeklappt,
habe das irgendwo hingetragen und dann ging es und es ist jetzt wirklich so,
dass ich,
ich habe jetzt gerade das Notebook hochgehoben und umgedreht
und der Kilian musste sie jetzt aufheben.
Ja, da ist ja auch so ein kleiner Stift angebrochen.
Aber das ist noch, wenn wir da reingucken, ist es schon noch eine Chiclet-Testator, oder?
Ne, die haben diese alten Butterfly-Switches,
die es so gab, die haben die irgendwie komplett revolutioniert.
Revolutioniert, da war da Johnny Ive ganz stolz drauf.
Ich höre jetzt schon den O-Ton, be revolutionized.
Ja, klar, we're very excited to present this.
Und Apple reinvented the keyboard.
Genau, also wenn euch das nächste Mal jemand
was von guter Apple-Hardware erzählt.
Ich bin immer noch ein großer Freund.
Ich bin auch ein großer Freund.
Der Body von dem Laptop ist halt super schön.
Das Geilste an dem Gerät,
und das fasziniert mich seit Jahren, ist,
du kannst den geschlossen hinstellen
und kannst mit einem Finger das Display aufmachen
und der Boden kommt nicht hinterher.
Es geht einfach auf.
Und das ist was, was sonst kein Laptop kann.
Das ist natürlich das übelste Kinderfeature.
Es gibt diverse Kleinigkeiten,
aber auch negative Kleinigkeiten, was viele Leute
an der Kastatur blöd finden, ist auch, dass
die Arrowkeys jetzt so den Platz
halt ausfüllen und nicht wie vorher, dass du
es nicht so gut ertasten kannst, von wegen, weil die links und rechts
auch flach sind, genauso flach wie oben und unten,
sondern dass links und rechts jetzt groß sind
und oben und unten sich den Platz einer Taste halt teilen.
Also blind zu bedienen ist, glaube ich,
schwieriger, also ohne hinzugucken.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Gewöhnungssache.
viel schlimmer. Ich weiß nicht, schlimmer finde ich
nicht, aber... Wer benutzt denn schon noch die
Error-Keys mal ganz im Ernst? H und KL, ne?
Okay, jetzt kommt der Wim-User in die durch.
Ctrl-1, Ctrl-P,
Ctrl-B, Ctrl-F. Und da ist der Emix-User.
Ich hab dann wirklich aufgehört,
die zu benutzen.
Deswegen. Okay.
Naja, ne, ist ja eigentlich...
Also es gibt der so
fertige Emix-Konfiguration,
Emix-Previewed ist so die,
die haben den
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das heißt,
aber die haben auf jeden Fall standardmäßig die Arrow-Keys ausgeschaltet.
Das machen viele.
Nach dem Motto, wenn du die Arrow-Keys benutzt,
bist du sowieso kein richtiger Emix-User.
Oh Mann, lass.
Ich habe das dann erstmal ausgemacht,
aber ich habe diese Kombination der Tasten,
die Anordnung der Tasten dann zum Anlass genommen,
um mal wirklich ein richtiger Emix-User zu werden.
Was ich nach dem Gerät noch ein bisschen interessant finde,
ist, ich habe selber noch kein Gerät mit der Touch Bar,
aber ich habe mich seit mittlerweile Monaten,
habe ich meinen Caps Lock in System Preferences
auf Escape gemappt, nur um mich schon mal
umzugewöhnen auf ein Gerät
mit Touchbar, sodass ich niemals das
Escape da oben drücken muss.
Das macht es ja auch recht angenehm. Caps Lock braucht man eh nicht.
Früher war das ja mal Controls und schwören auch
viele drauf. Auf Linux ist es halt bei mir
der Compose Key. Und der Compose Key
ist so viel mächtiger als alles andere.
Wer braucht schon Caps Lock auf so einer fetten Taste?
Wenn du schreien willst, dann musst
du einfach mal hier diese Taste anmachen.
Gewisse Sachen müssen ja einfach irgendwann mal
gesagt werden. Da hältst du Shift.
Das ist ja kein Windows, wo nach 5 Sekunden so ein Pop-Up aufgeht
von wegen, willst du das Schiff fest einstellen?
Oder bist du auf der Tastatur eingeschlafen?
Aber gibt es nicht für Wim-User
sogar Stempel im Bonusheft von der
Krankenkasse, wenn man das umstellt?
Weil dann die Kosten für Sehenschein
nicht sind, nur irgendwie billiger werden.
Großartig, aber das wäre
sehr möglich.
Ich sollte übrigens, wenn dieser Podcast von irgendwelchen Krankenkassen gehört,
nicht erzählen, dass ich Wim-Benutzer bin.
Meinst du wirklich?
Ich fände es super witzig, wenn irgendeine
Krankenkasse der Welt tatsächlich irgendwo
so einen Fragebogen hat, wo sind sie Vim-User?
Check.
Als Vim-Nutzer bist du
im Schnitt einfach schneller im Tippen,
weil du einfach mehr aufeinanderfolgende
Tastenanschläge machen musst, um die gleiche
Aktion durchzuführen. Als E-Max-Nutzer
hast du wesentlich gelenkigeren Featuren.
Weil du Tastenkombinationen mit
möglichst vielen Feigern gleichzeitig machen musst.
Das gefällt mir.
Aber noch ein Feature, was mir
negativ aufgestoßen ist,
das ist so ganz, ganz
banales eigentlich.
Ich gucke mir diese Touch Bar an, ja klar,
teilweise cool. Ich habe neulich
mit einer Kollegin was zusammen
debugged und die hatte, Visual Studio Code hat
einfach die Debug-Tasten auf die Touch Bar
gelegt mit
Step und Go Into und Step Out
und so weiter und so fort. Das fand ich nice.
Aber du guckst dir diese Touch Bar an und
ein paar Zentimeter oben drüber ist dieses super
geile Retina-Display
und du guckst dir die Touch Bar an
und sie ist pixelig.
im Vergleich zum Retina-Display ist die Touchbar
pixelig.
Das stimmt, ja, das ist interessant.
Das ist traurig.
Dafür ist die Technik gesehen super cool.
Das ist ja quasi ein WatchOS, was da drauf läuft.
Also quasi.
Da läuft ein eigenes OS drauf?
Da läuft ein eigenes Prozessor, der die Touchbar betreibt.
Komplett abgetrennt vom Rest des Systems.
Das ist natürlich ähnlich wie bei seiner.
Die werden wahrscheinlich asynchron miteinander kommunizieren.
Ist dir schon mal die Touchbar abgestürzt?
Ja, die Touchbar ist mir auch wirklich mal abgestürzt.
Interessant. Und dann?
Dann kam halt eine Error-Nachricht.
Also blau geleuchtet.
Das war nur eine Zahl oder so.
Und was macht man dann?
Computer neu starten?
Computer neu starten.
Mir ist die Maus abgestürzt.
Meine Maus hat sich aufgehängt.
Wenn dein eigenes Betriebsstipp draufläuft,
ist das völlig normal, dass ich die Komme abkühlen kann.
Meine Tastatur ist abgestürzt.
Das macht man dann.
Wir sind aber nicht an dem Punkt, wo Tastaturen...
Der Apple-Weg würde ja irgendwann
dahingehend weitergehen, dass wir
statt Trackpad, das ist ja übrigens
auf dem Gerät auch sehr angenehm groß, das muss ich nur mal
dazu sagen, das finde ich auch ein super
tolles Feature an der Generation. Unnötig groß.
Quatsch, du willst ja deine 15 Fingergesten
mit einem Fuß und zwei Hände.
Die Kollegin, mit der ich heute zusammengearbeitet habe,
die hatte auf ihrem MacBook für alles, wo ich
drei Fingergesten mache,
zum hin- und herfischen Zwischendescript, hat man da
vier Finger gebraucht.
Das ist glaube ich einfach die Default-Entstellung, oder?
Kann gut sein.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, das habe ich schon lange umgestellt.
Wo wollte ich gerade drauf hinaus?
Das Touchpad ist groß.
Nee, da habe ich bloß eingeworfen.
Achso, nee, der Apple-Weg wird ja irgendwann dahin führen,
dass wir die Tastatur und das Trackpad einfach abschaffen
und eine Glasscheibe hingeben.
Ob da jetzt ein iOS draufläuft
oder ob das einfach ein zweiter Display für macOS ist,
was dann auf zwei Glasscheiben irgendwie läuft.
Das würde ich noch zeigen.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl,
früher oder später werden sie die Tastatur komplett in die Software packen.
Aber das hättest du ja vor zehn Jahren schon machen können.
Hättest du, klar. Du hättest auch jetzt ein iPad hinlegen.
Es gab ja schon Designs vor zehn Jahren von Laptops,
die du zuklappst, einmal umdrehst und aufklappst
und dann ist es das gleiche Gerät,
weil einmal benutzt du den Teil zum Tippen
und das andere mal benutzt.
Trotzdem wird Apple sagen, die haben das Gerät erfunden.
Hört daran nichts.
Aber die Frage ist halt, kommen wir noch vorher
an den Zeitpunkt, wo wir irgendwie so haptisches Feedback
in Touch-Displays reinkriegen?
Die Jugend von heute, die lernt auf Glas zu tippen.
Also auf einer glatten Glasfläche.
Hashtag die Jugend von heute.
Ich ziehe mich nicht mehr dazu.
Nee, ich glaube das nicht, dass wir da hinkommen.
Also Leute, die viel tippen,
dafür wird sich die
mechanische Tastatur schon noch...
Die alte Nerdguard, die dann am Leben
bleibt und die auch heute noch
auf mechanischen Keyboards tippen.
Aber es gibt ja die Leute, die extra
sich richtig laute, richtig tief
klickende mechanische Keyboards daheim
entstellen. Ich bin übrigens froh, dass
dieser Kollege mit diesem Keyboard nicht mehr
neben mir im Büro sitzt. Ich glaube, das wird mich
wahnsinnig machen. Genau, ich bin einer von denen.
Das grenzt schon an asoziales Verhalten,
muss ich sagen. Ist das so ein lautes Ding,
schon richtig klackern?
Genau, es gibt ja da so verschiedene Stufen
von mechanischen Keyboards.
Erzähl uns doch mal ein bisschen was über mechanische Keyboards,
bitte. Okay, also
ich möchte jetzt bitte
eine detaillierte Beschreibung von den einzelnen Farben
von den Schaltern. Warum nehmen denn Leute
überhaupt mechanische Keyboards anstatt
solchen, die in den Notebooks drin sind oder solchen, die
meistens auf den Schreibtischen
stehen, die so Gumminoppen haben.
Die Antwort auf die Frage ist,
du hast
einen Druckpunkt, einen definierten.
Also die,
wenn du dir ein Diagramm malst, wo du auf der
auf der Y-Achse
den Weg hast, den die Taste runternimmt,
also den die Taste nimmt und
auf der X-Achse
Kraft hast, die du aufwenden musst,
dann gibt es da einen Knick
und das ist der Druckpunkt.
Den kannst du erfüllen.
Und das sollte auch der Punkt sein, an dem
die Tastatur
den Tastendruck registriert.
Und das Signal auslöst, dass du die Tastendruck
hast. Genau.
Und wenn man
seine Tastatur gut kennt und wenn man
weiß, dass die
Mechanical...
Das war auf dem letzten Kongress. Ich war leider nicht auf dem
Mechanical Keyboard Meetup da,
Aber ich habe es mir einfach
Freude vorgeschickt.
Genau, auf jeden Fall ist es
bei den Mechanischen...
Sorry, ich war ja zu klippern.
Es ist bei
bei mechanischen Keyboards ist es so, wenn ihr euch vorstellt,
auf der Y-Achse habt ihr
den Weg, den die Taste zurücklegt. Also
wenn ich die runterdrücke, dann geht der
zurückgelegte Weg nach oben. Und auf der
X-Achse habt ihr die Kraft, die
ihr aufwendet,
sodass der
habt ihr in dieser Kurve, die ihr malt,
einen Knick drin.
Und das ist der sogenannte Druckpunkt.
Den kann man erfüllen.
Und das ist bei mechanischen Keyboards auch...
Also ich drücke die Taste ein Stück rein
und ab einem gewissen Punkt wird es schwerer.
Und das ist der Moment, in dem auch das Signal
ausgelöst wird.
Die Kurve kann ganz unterschiedlich aussehen.
Das ist nicht nur einfach eine Linear.
Wenn es Linear wäre, wäre es am schlimmsten wahrscheinlich,
weil ich dann keinerlei Informationen hätte,
wann ist jetzt eigentlich der Punkt erreicht.
Genau.
Du kannst es ausweilen, also entweder du machst den Weg gleichmäßig runter oder du hast eine Kraft und die erhöhst du immer weiter und immer weiter und irgendwann kommt ein Punkt, wo du dann über ganz wenig Kraft ganz weit runterdrückst.
Das ist der Druckpunkt.
Und bei den mechanischen Tastaturen ist es so, dass die auch in der Nähe von diesem Druckpunkt auch den Tastendruck registrieren und dann das Signal schicken, dass die Taste gedrückt wurde.
dass das zusammenfällt.
Das heißt, du kannst mit, wenn du
deine Tastatur gut kennst, kannst du relativ gut tippen,
ohne dass du die Taste jemals
den Boden der Tastatur
berühren musst. Das ist bei
so einen Tastaturen, wie sie
in den Notebooks verbaut sind oder wie sie auf den
meisten Schreibtischen heutzutage stehen,
nicht so. Da musst du die Taste immer runterdrücken,
weil dann
eine Gumminoppe für so einen
ähnlichen kleinen Druckpunkt sorgt, aber
dass die Taste richtig runtergedrückt werden muss, dass sich die Kontakte
schließen und der Tastendruck registriert wird und
weit auseinander, der Druckpunkt und die Tastenregistrierung.
Außerdem ist der dann so schwammig
und nicht so schön knackig,
wie bei so einem mechanischen
Scheitern. Das ist was, was mich bei der
Tastatur von dir tatsächlich so ein bisschen
gestört hat, dass die Tasten,
wenn ich sie reingedrückt habe, so ein bisschen
Spiel hatten und erst
irgendwann
so nach einem halben Zentimeter
Eindrücken gefühlt erst wirklich
registriert wurde und dann hat es so knack gemacht,
dann war die Taste gedrückt.
Das hat mich, ehrlich gesagt, eher gestört.
Ich glaube, das ist auch eine Gewohnheitssache.
Aber ich finde das persönlich sehr angenehm.
Und es gibt jetzt diese Kurve, von der ich erzählt habe,
also Kraft zu Weg,
dafür gibt es verschiedene Schalter,
die sich unterschiedlich verhalten.
Größtenteils hat da die Firma Cherry.
Die kennt ihr vielleicht noch früher von hochwertigen Tastaturen,
die auch früher mal bei PCs mitgeliefert wurden.
Und da gibt es verschiedene Schalter und für die Tastatur-Nutz sind meistens die Cherry MX-Switches die interessantesten.
Sind das schon die, wo man irgendwie in Farben unterscheidet?
Genau, davon gibt es verschiedene Farben. Ich probiere jetzt hier gerade mal kurz eine Übersicht zu nehmen.
Das ist auch das, wo sich Gamer stundenlang darüber unterhalten können, oder?
Genau, also eine andere Gruppe von Leuten, für die es interessant ist, ist für Gamer, weil die normalen Tastaturen meistens, ich glaube aber eher aufgrund der Elektronik, nicht dazu in der Lage sind, sehr viele Tastendrucke gleichzeitig zu registrieren.
Also wichtig ist ja, und das ist ja auch das, was ein teures Klavier oder ein teures E-Piano von einem Keyboard unterscheidet, ist die Anschlagsdynamik und wie sie es anfühlt.
Zum Beispiel, wie schnell eine Taste wieder hochkommt,
damit ich möglichst schnell wieder draufdrücken kann.
Ich finde es so ein paar verschiedene
dieser Kurven, die du gerade beschrieben hast.
Für die verschiedenen Farben von Switches.
Genau.
Hier habe ich jetzt ein Diagramm.
Da sieht man für die
verschiedenen farbigen Cherry MX Switches
dieses Diagramm, was ich beschrieben hatte,
ist allerdings umgedreht.
Also auf der Y-Achse
ist die Kraft und auf der X-Achse ist der Weg.
und ich habe die blauen
und ich habe einen mit blauen
und einen mit grün.
Das ist auch in den Show-Notes, packen wir das mal rein.
Genau, da sieht man
der Punkt, wo es diesen Knick macht, das ist die
Kraft, die man aufwinden muss
zum Aktivieren. Also bei blau
sieht man es, dass es einen sehr, sehr definierten
Druckpunkt hat, wo es dann
wenn man den erstmal erreicht hat, bei 60
Newton?
Also das ist jetzt ja, man sieht
eine relativ gerade, lineare
Kurve, dann kommt so ein Hügelchen drauf
und dann geht die wieder, nach dem Hügel geht sie
auf der gleichen Linie parallel weiter
und das ist quasi dieser
Knackpunkt, wo man mal ganz kurz
mehr Kraft braucht.
Und das ist dann auch der Moment, in dem
dann ausgelöst wird.
Dahinter geht es hart nach oben,
also das ist der untere Anschlag.
Genau, das ist dann ganz unten.
Da kann man dann so viel Kraft
aufwenden, wie man möchte und es geht nicht
weiter.
Ah ja.
Und die unterscheiden sich aber nicht nur in ihrem Druckpunkt, sondern sie unterscheiden sich auch in ihrem Krach, den sie machen. Und die Blauen sind da besonders unbeliebt bei den Büronachbarn, aber haben halt auch den schönsten Druckpunkt.
Hast du die irgendwie ausprobiert? Kann man die irgendwie, muss man sich da drei Tastaturen bestellen oder kann man die im Laden noch ausprobieren?
Also ich weiß jetzt keinen lokalen Laden hier, wo man wirklich mal alle ausprobieren kann.
Man kann sich bei einigen Versandtendern, die haben so eine Probe-Packs.
Das ist dann einfach eine kleine Tastatur mit acht Tasten, die auch keine Elektronik hat,
wo man einfach nur mal auf die Tasten drücken kann, um zu gucken.
Und das kann man dann wieder zurückschicken.
Oder als Ersatz für einen Fidget Cube.
Ja.
Das ist ja auch das wahrscheinlich, was
so Luftpolsterfolie
so befriedigend macht.
Ich drücke drauf ein bisschen und habe
einen gewissen Punktkraft dazu gemacht.
Aber es geht also,
wem das noch nicht gut genug
und noch nicht laut genug ist,
gibt es halt immer noch die alten
IBM
Buckling Spring
Keyboards,
die wirklich früher bei den
IBM Workstations mitverkauft werden.
Die kennt ihr vielleicht noch,
Wenn ihr ein bisschen älter seid,
weiß ich so, Anfang der 90er
war das ein sehr beliebtes Modell
und da war es fast das Einzige, was es gab.
Das sind diese richtig hohen, beigen Tassen.
Die einzige Farbe aus der Computer in der Zeit sind.
Diese dreckige, weiße
Beige. Die haben da nicht
so einen mechanischen Schalter
mit so einer Feder, sondern
die haben wirklich eine richtige Feder.
Und wenn ihr schon mal aus dem
Kugelschreiber eine Feder ausgebaut habt
und die so zwischen zwei
Fingern gehalten habt, dann kennt ihr das
die dann so wegschnippst.
Genau, nach demselben Prinzip funktionieren die auch.
Dann drückt man
runter und irgendwann
machen die jetzt so einen Buckel
und dadurch wird der
Druckpunkt erreicht bei denen.
Weil sich die Feder zur Seite
wegbewegt? Ja genau, die schnippt dann so weg.
Das passiert
innerhalb der Taste, wenn du die
runterdrückst. Und die haben
auf jeden Fall noch einen schöneren Druckpunkt und ist aber
nochmal richtig viel lauter.
Die kann man doch auch nur eine bestimmte Anzahl
überleben, doch auch bloß eine bestimmte
Anzahl Anschläge, oder?
Die sind
wesentlich robuster als die
Cherry MX-Switches auch.
Also die halten wirklich
ewig lange, also Millionen von Tastenanschlägen.
Also ich weiß, eine Tastatur, die ich mal
hatte, die relativ billig
war, die hat quasi bloß aus drei
Layern bestanden. Ich habe die mal
zerlegt, um die zu waschen.
Das waren zwei Folien, wo die Kontakte auseinandergehalten wurden von so einer gelochten Silikonmatte.
Und wenn man da drauf gedrückt hat, hat man quasi die eine Folie durch diese Silikonmatte in die andere Folie reingedrückt.
oben drüber war nochmal eine Silikonmatte,
wo quasi so als erhabene
Punkte, ähnlich wie bei so einer Luftpolsterfolie,
die Knöpfe waren
und da lagen dann diese Plastetasten
drauf mit einem Stift.
Man hatte überhaupt
keine mechanischen Teile,
sondern es war quasi nur ein Stück Silikon,
wo man dann einzelne
Noppen
verbogen hat.
Auf jeden Fall hat IBM
hat sich das früher patentieren lassen,
das Buckling Spring Prinzip.
und die bauen ja jetzt
keine Computer und keine Keyboards mehr
und es hat dann eine Firma namens
Unicomp aufgekauft und
die bauen die heute immer noch.
Musst du mal gucken, die haben auch eine ganz
schicke Homepage.
Die sieht nämlich auch aus wie Anfang der
90er. Oh nein, die haben eine neue
Homepage. Oh nein, ich hab die
gerade aufgemacht. Die sieht nicht mehr so schön aus.
Musst du mal in der Wayback Machine gucken.
Vor ein, zwei Jahren sah die noch
so richtig nach Anfang der
90er aus. PC-Keyboard.com
Mit einem Shop,
wo man anrufen kann, also Internetseite
mit Katalog und dann zum Beispiel anrufen
und bestellen und so. Aber scheinbar haben sie das
auch. Aber die sehen ja auch so urig aus. Wenn man jetzt auf
so einem Nerd-Lad geht,
also thinkgeek.com, gibt es
doch auch das Keyboard.
Das sind doch diese Keyboards für
100, 100,
3000 Dollar
kostet es. Nee, nee, nicht diese LED-Dinger,
wo du jede Taste anders
mit einem anderen Display bemalen kannst,
sondern das Keyboard ist einfach
so ein schwarzes Teil, das hat überhaupt keine
Beschriftung.
Das kostet auch 120 Euro. Hast du das nicht
sogar irgendwie gehabt?
Ich habe das mal auf Arbeit gehabt, aber
ich habe das auch überall angepriesen, aber es wollte
irgendwie keiner haben, weil Leute nicht klarkommen,
wenn keine Beschriftung auf dem Schick sind.
Obwohl das noch besser ist, als wenn du
irgendwie in Software das Layout wechselst
und dann irgendwie andere Tasten
Ihr beide tippt ja auf US-Layouts,
Ich tippe auf einem physisch-deutschen Layout auch mit US-Layout.
Das stimmt sowieso nicht überein,
mit was ich tippe.
Ich habe extra eine Woche lang länger mit,
auf Arbeit eine Woche länger mit dem Windows-PC gearbeitet,
der mir ursprünglich hingestellt wurde,
weil ich noch länger nach einem Laden
suchen musste, der mir einen
Mac mit einem
US-Layout zuschickt.
Ich habe trotzdem nur das doofe International.
US-International ist das Beste.
Das ist US-Layout plus
gut geformte Entertaste.
Nein, das ist halt das US-Layout mit der bescheuerten europadeutschen Enter-Taste.
Also es gibt ja die zwei US-Layout, sind das alles so längliche Tasten, die alle mehr oder weniger, also die Spezialtasten sind alles rechtecke, die quasi waagerecht im Layout liegen.
Und auf der,
an dem deutschen Tastaturlayout
oder auch an dem ISO,
nee, in dem ISO-Englischen ist es eine,
in dem ISO-Englischen ist es eine
senkrecht stehendes Rechteck,
die Entertaste, richtig?
Ja, genau so wie bei Hendrik.
Und bei Hendrik ist es,
achso, du meinst, dass ich nochmal ein Wahnsinn auskümmelde,
dass die wirklich senkrecht stehendes Rechteck
und nicht so geformt wie so ein umgedrehtes L ist.
Genau.
Ah, okay, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Genau, und bei Hendrik ist es,
Hendrik hat ein deutsches, oder?
Nee, das ist ein US-International.
Ach, das ist ein US-International.
Da ist die Enter-Taste so ein umgedrehtes L.
Aber auf dem Deutschen ist die auch so ein umgedrehtes L.
Okay, das ist das gleiche. Es gibt übrigens
eine Webseite, die machen wir
dann nochmal in die Shownotes,
mit ganz, mit allen
Apple-Tastaturen
abfotografiert in allen Layouts.
Richtig schön zum Angucken.
Oh, die Power-Seiten.
So was toll.
Ich suche ja für meine Wohnung noch nach Postern,
weil ich noch ein paar leere Wände habe.
Ich glaube, vielleicht layoute ich mir das alles nebeneinander
und lasse mir das dann irgendwo plocken.
Das wäre natürlich auch schick.
Vielleicht ist eine Landschaft doch schöner.
Vielleicht wäre man mit Julius
quatschend.
Das ist witzig.
Ich kenne genau zwei Neo-User
und die heißen beide Julius.
Fällt mir gerade so auf.
Nie gemerkt.
Zufall?
Ich denke nicht.
Vielleicht sollten wir mit dem Neo-User quatschen,
was die so von Keyboard-Layouts halten.
Ich kenne leider überhaupt keinen
Dvorak-User, also niemanden, der aktiv
auf Dvorak schreibt, aber dafür
Neoyuser.
Kollege Felix von mir auf Arbeit,
der auf einer zweigeteilten
Tastatur,
wo du die Arme gerade
hinlegst
und die dann halt bei deiner Hände
einen halben Meter auseinander sind,
der hat eine zweigeteilte Tastatur
und das mit Dvorak-Layout.
Super cool.
Unbenutzbar für Gäste.
Also ich bitte ja teilweise, wie gesagt,
ich bitte ja teilweise Leute,
mit denen ich zusammenarbeite,
mir bereits einen Gäste-Wim zu installieren,
wenn ich mal an deren Computer arbeiten muss.
Aber bei der Tastatur hat es da bei mir
echt auch aufgehört. Da muss man dann
eine zweite Tastatur anschließen.
Ich kann nichts bedienen bei dir.
Also ich tippe auch
auf Dorak.
Ach so? Ja.
Dann haben wir ja sogar jemanden hier.
Bei meinen anderen
Notebooks vorher hatte ich auch die Tasten
ausgetauscht.
Aber hier habe ich mich nicht getraut
bei den Leuten.
Man hatte eh schon rausfallende Tasten
und andere Probleme mit dem Keyboard
muss man ja nicht noch 50% der Tasten
kaputt machen, indem man die einfach nur oben ordnet.
Ach, du bist halt nicht Dworak, Josef.
Warum Dworak und nicht
Neo?
Das ist eine schwierige Frage.
Ich mach das schon 10 Jahre, damals war Neo
glaube ich einfach noch nicht so ein Ding.
Neo ist mehr auf Deutsch
oder ist Neo auch
ohne Ahnung.
Das Feature von Neo
ist ja generell, dass man in so Ebenen arbeitet
und durch die Modify-Arkeys durch die Ebenen
durchswitchen kann, wo dann alles zugegängig
teilt. Aber ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das primär
auf deutsche User ausgerichtet ist.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch ein bisschen Background geben.
Erzähl mal, was ist ein Dworak überhaupt?
Genau, also wenn ihr so diese normale
Tastatur, diese Querti
internationalen anguckt,
habt ihr euch ja
vielleicht schon mal gefragt, warum sind
diese Tasten denn so angeordnet, wie sie angeordnet
sind? Und die Antwort auf
diese Frage ist, das war historisch
bedingt, weil
man musste immer,
wenn man getippt hat, Tasten,
wenn man normalen Text getippt hat,
Tasten drücken, die nicht zu nah
beieinander sind, weil sonst haben sich
die Stempel in der Schreibmaschine einander
verhangen. Das schaffe ich regelmäßig, wenn ich auf
meiner Schreibmaschine tippe. Du hast eine Schreibmaschine?
Ich glaube, ich eine Schreibmaschine. Ich bin doch ein echter
Hipster. Nimmst du die manchmal mit in die Vorlesung?
Das habe ich noch nicht gemacht. Ich habe sie
früher mal in die Schule mitgenommen und wurde von meiner Biolahre
gleich wieder rausgeschmissen. Aber ich nutze sie heutzutage
eigentlich nur, um meiner Schwester Briefe zu schreiben,
weil sie mir auf ihrer Schreibmaschine Briefe schreibt.
Du weißt, dass man das dann nachvollziehen kann.
Das ist eine komplett mechanische DDR-Reiseschreibmaschine.
Okay.
Von meinem Opa.
Also wenn euch die Buckling Spring immer noch nicht laut genug ist.
Also meiner musst du richtig rein.
Da kriegst du erst richtig Krampf in den Fingern nach.
Nach auch nur einem Absatz.
Das ist schon richtig weh.
Gibt es da Mods, wo Leute aus einer Schreibmaschine
eine Tastatur gebaut haben?
Das willst du nicht.
Habe ich mal so einen Steampunk-Rechner
gesehen, so einen richtigen Steampunk-Fanboy,
der sich das zusammengewastelt hat.
Das sah schon fantastisch aus.
Bei Layout kommt
aus der Schreibmaschinenzeit, damit
die Stempel nicht verklemmen.
Die Tasten müssten möglichst weit auseinander sein,
damit du möglichst häufig
aufeinanderfolgende Tasten
erstens nicht zu schnell nacheinander tippst,
dass du nicht zu schnell tippst, aber ich glaube auch,
weil einfach das ja korreliert hat,
wo ist die Taste und wo ist der Hammer
in dieser Hammer-Reihe,
Ich glaube, die Geschwindigkeit ist relativ wurscht,
aber wenn du halt zwei, die Stempel
gleichzeitig vorjagst, die nebeneinander liegen,
dann klemmen die sofort fest.
Also richtig wurscht ist es nicht, weil die auch eine Geschwindigkeit
haben, mit der sie sich wieder zurücksetzen.
Gut, dass du
sich in so eine endliche weiter treiben kannst.
Aber anyway, Quertz und Querti ist halt
das, dass die nur häufig
nacheinander tippen, möglichst weit auseinander sind.
Ja, also da kommt Querti her.
Da gibt es natürlich noch diverse Anpassungen
für diverse Länder.
Nehmen wir die Franzosen, tippen wir auf Aserti.
äh, ja, das ist jetzt wirklich
esoterisch.
Wir werfen mal den Link in die
Show Notes, da sind wirklich von allen Ländern
die Layouts der
Tapestaturen, die Apple anbietet, aus ihrer
Support-Seite.
Es ist halt erstaunlich, was es da für eine
Bandbreite gibt.
Aber das unterliegende
Layout, wie die
Tasten geformt sind, gibt es eigentlich
nur die 105
und die 104er
Varianten, die mit dem hohen und die mit dem
breiten Enter, oder? Gibt es da noch mehr?
Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich meine, Apple an sich ist ja schon ein bisschen
seltsam, so von den Formen von der
Tastatur. Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Aber anyway, also wir haben jetzt
die Tasten, die möglichst weit auseinander sind und Leute haben sich gedacht, man kann
schneller tippen, indem man eigentlich die Tasten
anders sortiert und zwar
bei Neo ist es so, ne Quatsch,
bei Dwork, jetzt musst du weiter erzählen. Genau, bei
Dwork ist es so, dass man
auf der Grundreihe, auf der
linken Hand hat man alle
Vokale.
Also A, E, E, U.
Und
auf der
Grundreihe, auf der rechten Hand hat man so die
Konsonanten, die man am häufigsten braucht.
Die Prinzipien ist eigentlich, dass man
immer abwechselnd die linke und die rechte Hand benutzt.
Weil einfach
es schwieriger ist,
schnell auf der
linken Hand zwei hintereinander folgende
Sachen, als wenn man die Hände
wechseln kann. Und außerdem
ist sie
Verteilung der Tasten in Reihen
dann so, dass die häufiger
benutzten Tasten auf der Grundreihe sind.
Die, die man ein bisschen weniger
häufig benutzt, sind oben und
die am wenigsten häufig benutzen, sind ganz unten.
Bei QWERTY merke ich,
dass man erstaunlich viele Wörter
eher mit links tippt als mit rechts.
Interessant, darüber Statistiken zu machen.
Bei DWORK an sich ist es aber auf die englische Sprache
intimiert. Es gibt auch ein Dwork Deutsch,
aber das supporten
dann nicht so viele Betriebssysteme
und so weiter. Also ich benutze seit
mindestens 15 Jahren
eigentlich nur noch das
US-Layout hauptsächlich,
weil halt Sonderzeichen, die man
beim Programmieren braucht, nicht auf einer
dritten Tastenbelegung sind. Klammern,
geschwungene und eckige, die liegen halt so viel sinnvoller
auf dem US-Layout.
Also deswegen frage ich mich manchmal,
wenn die deutschen Programmierensprachen erfunden hätten
mit ihrem Layout.
Ich frage mich auch manchmal, wie es aussehen würde, wenn die Chinesen als erstes Programmiersprachen erfunden hätten. Hätten die Englisch genommen oder hätten die chinesische Zeichen gekämpft? Aber eine Sache, wo mir auffällt, dass tatsächlich QWERTY eine Berechtigung hat, wieder aktuell ist, wenn man swiped, also wenn man auf ein, ihr seid beide iPhone-Nutzer, da gibt es sowas glaube ich nicht, aber
Third-Party-Keyboards, aber die nutzen wenige Leute.
Wo man quasi mit einem, ohne Absetzen,
auf der Smartphone-Tastatur hin und her wischt,
um Wörter zu schreiben,
ist es, glaube ich, einfach aufgrund der Unterscheidbarkeit
mit einem QWERTY-Layout besser Wörter zu tippen.
Zwei Anmerkungen dazu.
Einerseits, ich behaupte, das liegt auch an der Gewöhnung,
was das Layout angeht.
dass natürlich, wenn du das Layout gewöhnt bist,
du besser weißt, in welcher Richtung es heißt.
Wenn du jetzt die meisten Tasten, die du ständig brauchst,
auf einer Zeile hast und die abwechselnd sind,
dann wischst du quasi nur grob hin und her.
Und das macht es wesentlich schwerer,
für diesen Erkennungsalgorithmus zu unterscheiden,
was du wirklich tust.
Die andere Anmerkung ist,
dass das natürlich noch ein ganz anderer Input-Paradigm ist,
ein anderes Input-Paradigma,
was viel sinnvoller noch abgebildet werden kann
über eine komplett andere Tastatur.
Da gab es auf Android mal so eine coole Sache,
die hieß 8-Pen.
ich glaube die haben sie aus dem Store genommen
die wollten es komplett neu erfinden
wie du swipest im Sinne von du hast einen Kreis
in der Mitte und all deine Swipes fangen
in diesem Kreis an und hast du daraus
einen Strich in die
obere linke Ecke quasi in alle Ecken
von der Tastatur
und die Buchstaben hängen alle an diesen Strichen
dran, links und rechts und du swipest
nur aus diesem Kreis, aus der Mitte kommen Kreise
und quasi nur
8er Zeichen
in die verschiedensten Winkel gedreht
um diese einzelnen Linien, je nachdem
welcher Reihe, wie oft du da rauskommst
und wo du reinkommst und wo du reingehst, hast du die einzelnen
Buchstaben benutzt.
Ich habe das mal einen Monat ausprobiert.
Anfangs warst du da super langsam, wie bei jeder
anderen Tastatur, aber das hat sich einfach so
angenehm ergonomisch angeführt, weil du wirklich
nur Kreise geswipst. Du hast nicht mehr
irgendwelche komischen Bewegungen, wo bei manchen
Wörtern sehr schwierig wird, sondern du hast
sehr cool einfach nur Kreismuster reingemalt.
Da könnte ich mir jetzt fast noch
ganz andere Konzepte vorstellen.
Es gibt so Eingabemechanismen
für Behinderte,
wo du
als Eingabe nur die Maus nimmst.
Das war jetzt irgendwie so eine Demo
und so ein Tool auf KDE,
was es mal gab.
Da hast du quasi ein Zeichen angewählt
und danach hat es ausgewählt statistisch,
um das Wort quasi zu vervollständigen,
welche Buchstaben statistisch gesehen
am wahrscheinlichsten als nächstes kommen.
Und hat dir das so fett eingeblendet,
ich glaube übereinander.
Du hast bloß durch nach oben und unten
Wischen ausgewählt,
welcher Buchstabe als nächstes kommt und hast dich
so wie in so einem Jump'n'Run durch so
von rechts reinfliegende
Buchstaben bewegt und das könnte man
eigentlich auch ganz cool machen, weil die
Autovervollständigung ist ja ein eingebautes
Feature in den Tastaturen, dass du quasi
dass du quasi
wischst, wie
bei diesem 8-Pan-Verfahren im Kreis,
aber dass das
Layout nicht statisch ist,
wo welche Tastatur, äh, wo welcher
ist, sondern dass es quasi
versucht zu erraten, was du für ein Wort tippen willst,
sondern einen möglichst kurzen Weg hast.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das dann am Ende nicht
verwirrender wäre, als es hilft.
Das ist eine Frage der Gewöhnung.
Was man Mac OS generell für coole Inputmöglichkeiten hat.
Wenn es zumindest als nächstes jemand
baut, möchte ich bitte
Alimente dafür.
Schau mal nach, ich würde mich mal interessieren, weil es gibt ja generell auch
diese Switch-Control-Sachen, wo du mit so einem Blasröhrchen
oder mit einem Schalter am Kopf komplett den
Rechner bedienst.
Ich habe mir das noch gar nicht angeschaut, wie Text-Input da
funktioniert, aber da habe ich mal ein fantastisches
Video gesehen von einem, der demonstriert hat,
wie er so Xcode bedient und
tatsächlich iOS-Applikationen baut
und der hatte aufgrund von
seiner Behinderung nur die Möglichkeit, mit dem Kopf einen Schalter
zu bedienen und der hat Videos
geschnitten mit Final Cut Pro und das sah beeindruckend
aus. Der ist schneller das Ding bedient, als ich mit
einer Maus dahinterher gekommen wäre. Im Endeffekt
konnte Stephen Hawking mit
seinem Augenlid auch fast
in Echtzeit-Texte machen.
Für Stephen Hawking,
die vor
ich glaube, vor einem Jahr, die
ein Software-Update für
seinen Input-Mechanismus gebaut hat,
das waren die Swift-Key-Leute.
Die haben da nochmal
komplett für Eden-R-Custom-Software geschrieben.
Fand ich super cool.
Auf dem Meetup
in San Francisco, auf dem ich war, hat auch
einer von den Leuten, die da gewesen waren,
ein selbstentwickeltes Eingabekonzept vorgestellt,
was mit Spracherkennung
funktioniert hat, aber nicht Spracherkennung,
dass du
einfach gesagt hast, was du schreiben
willst, sondern Spracherkennung für Programmierung,
wo du nicht sagen möchtest,
Klammer auf, schweifte Klammer auf, oder
Braces, Brackets, was ich auch immer durcheinanderschmeiße,
ehrlich gesagt, sondern der hat
sich Laute genommen, die
möglichst gut unterscheidbar sind
und auf die hat er dann
Zeichen gemappt und du hast sie gesprochen
und dann hattest du diese Zeichen und da hast du
Also ne, warte,
er hat nicht Laute genommen, er hat Wörter
genommen, er hat Wörter genommen
und zwar Wörter, die sich gut unterscheiden
lassen, weil sie unterschiedlich klingen, dann hast du
Wörter gesprochen,
um damit einzelne Zeichen zu tippen.
Und ich dachte, das geht jetzt eher auf so eine
semantische Ebene, wo er dann sagt, neue Klasse
mit diesen Properties und
lässt dir dein Programm
dann möglichst viel Boulder Plate einfügen.
Aber der hat dann...
Das gab es vor 15 Jahren schon in der Java-Welt.
Natürlich gab es das.
Da hast du Grafen gemalt.
Oh Gott, UML-Diagramme direkt im Code übersetzen.
Ja, ja, ja. Da gab es eine ganze Forschungsarbeit.
Nämlich ein Video
auf YouTube von so einem Typen, der versucht,
Ich glaube, das war ein Windows Vista,
was er da in dem Screen Recording-Film
und das ist da von einem Texteditor
und versucht mit der Microsoft-Spracheingabe
da Code zu schreiben.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was das für eine Sprache war.
Das hat eigentlich keine Rolle.
Und er diktiert da halt wirklich Zeichen für Zeichen
und Wort für Wort was rein.
Und es ist halt unglaublich mühsam.
Und alles Dritte ist halt Bullshit.
Und er will das wieder löschen.
Und dann haut das aus den Löschkommentar auch mit rein.
Und da versteht es den Löschkommentar erst als solchen.
Und dann löscht er viel zu viel.
Und dann muss man die ganze Zeit versuchen, nicht zu lachen.
aber wird halt immer frustrierter auch währenddessen.
Das ist einfach ein großartiges Video.
Das war der Teil, den ich an dem Buch
1984 am unrealistischsten fand.
Dass sich
Winston, William,
Winston Smith
auf Arbeit hinsetzt und in sein
Speech-Write reindiktiert,
anstatt auf einer Tastatur zu tippen.
Es klingt halt futuristisch.
Ob es das wirklich ist, ist halt die andere Sache.
Aber wir haben jetzt einen Alexa hier
bald rumstehen.
dass das allgegenwärtig
Dinge dann annimmt
als, naja,
wir haben ja letztens schon mal, glaube ich, drüber gewähnt,
ob wir eine Folge hatten oder nicht,
dass es natürlich auch ziemlich dumme Plattformen sind und die auch nur
die einfachsten Intents verstehen, ja klar, haben wir eine Folge drüber,
über nie wieder Rosenstolz.
Nie wieder Rosenstolz.
Das ist natürlich
auf einem ganz anderen Level, aber
man könnte argumentieren, dass das auf jeden Fall
resistent in die Richtung geht.
Also wenn ich dem Ding bloß sagen muss, mach mal das Licht an,
mach mal dieses Lied an, wenn ich dem das meinetwegen zweimal
sagen muss, okay.
Aber wenn ich den ganzen Tag Text eingebe irgendwo,
und zwar Text, der auch noch
formatiert sein soll, mit Klammern
in den richtigen Einrückungen und so weiter und so fort,
dann habe ich keinen Bock,
dem dreimal zu erklären, dass er jetzt
bitte eine Klammer wieder zumachen soll.
Es gab früher schon Diktiergeräte, Leute,
oder haben eine Sekretärin das vordiktiert?
Da ist einfach die Eingabe, ich lege meine Hand
auf so ein mechanisches Gerät drauf und mein
Gehirn, ich muss überhaupt nicht mehr bewusst darüber nachdenken,
wenn ich ein Wort denke,
tippen meine Finger von alleine.
Man muss das doch nicht auch noch aussprechen.
Aber das wenigste von Programmieren ist ja,
dass du wirklich so ein Programm vom Anfang bis Ende
runterschreibst.
Ich schreibe meine Programme immer von Anfang bis Ende runter.
Wenn du der AI erklärst, was dein Programm tun soll
und der fügt halt einfach das bisschen Code,
was bis dahin einfach komplett als Wallerplate
angesehen wird, ein. Das ist doch auch eine
Idee, wie man das angehen könnte.
Das würde mich mal interessieren, ob es da schon
Forschungsarbeiten gibt. Du hast
Quelltext, den erklärt
jemand als Spracher,
als Text oder als Schließtext.
Und das Programm lernt quasi diese
Erklärung zu Quelltext. Es gab tatsächlich schon
ein Machine Learning Model, das aufgrund von Screenshots,
von Software, also von Mockups, die
Webseiten bzw. iOS-Apps rausgeneriert hat.
Das war dann
bedingt gut, hat das funktioniert,
aber das gibt es schon.
Ich meine, die Logik der Hälfte ist noch
was ganz anderes, aber hey.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall neuronale Netze, die neuronale
Netze tunen. Großartig.
Das nennt sich Feedback-Loop.
Ja, wir machen einen außenrum.
Was macht ihr eigentlich, wenn ihr ab morgen
arbeitslos seid, weil ihr keine Software mehr
entwickeln müsst, weil das alles neuronale
Netze für euch macht? Das ist ja wunderbar.
Dann neuronale Netze entwickeln.
Genau. Aber die werden noch von
neuronalen Netzen entwickelt.
Dann fahre ich
ein selbstfahrendes Auto.
Selbstfahre oder Taxi fahre.
Ich werde ein Auto.
Klar kann man sich die Frage
stellen.
ich behaupte einfach mal, dass gerade
die Softwareentwicklung eins der
späteren Gefilde sein wird, was davon
betroffen ist, beziehungsweise noch nicht.
Vielleicht sieht das in fünf Jahren ganz anders aus. Vielleicht ist es dann
plötzlich Softwareentwicklung, das sich komplett wegautomatisiert
und wir brauchen nur noch, keine Ahnung,
was ist davon nicht
betroffen? Du musst immer noch
das Scrum von den Menschen lernen lassen.
Ja, du bist dann der Scrum Master von drei AIs oder
was? Ich glaube, ab einem
bestimmten Punkt ist auch der Jobverlust
dann nicht mehr das größte Problem,
sondern mehr so, wie kriegt man die Maschinen,
wieder tot.
Also ich...
In 20 Jahren bin ich,
werde ich vom
Maschinentherapeuten zum Maschinenverschrotter
gelernt haben.
Ist das was Quality Land?
Ja.
Da gibt es übrigens einen sehr interessanten Podcast
genau zu dem Thema, Singularity FM.
Okay.
Das ist von einem
Kanadier, der lädt sich
mal interessante Leute ein
und spricht mit ihnen über
die technologische Singularität,
Zukunftskonzepte
und hat auch öfter mal
Science-Fiction-Autoren da.
Das klingt cool.
Kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Im physikalischen Sinne
bekommen wir den Begriff Singularität immer wieder erklärt,
dass das das Innere eines schwarzen Loches
und der Anfang des Universums ist.
Aber in diesem technologischen
Szenario
irgendwann selbstständig und verdrängen die Menschen.
Was bedeutet da Singularität?
Das Konzept kommt daher,
dass sich die technologische
Entwicklung so weit beschleunigt,
dass sie irgendwann an einem Punkt
ankommt, wo Maschinen schlauer
sind als Menschen.
Die Idee dabei an der Singularität
ist, dass wir,
an dem Punkt, wo die Maschinen schlauer sind als wir,
ist es für uns
momentan überhaupt nicht vorauszusehen,
was dann passiert, weil die sind ja dann
schlauer als wir
wie sollen wir das mit unserem
Intellekt begreifen
was danach kommt und das ist
einfach der Punkt, der genau wie beim
schwarzen Loch, kann ich reingucken
man kann nie wieder rauskommen, das ist einfach
ein Punkt an dem
an dem wir
wo der Ereignishorizont überschritten ist
und wir nicht mehr wissen, was dahinter passiert
und es entwickelt sich, ab da
steigert es sich ins Unendliche
Genau, also die Idee ist auch, dass es sich dann so schnell weiterentwickelt, dass es ins Bodenlose wächst und es einfach gegen das Unendliche strebt.
Gruselig.
Interessant.
Ja, Jupp, damit hast du jetzt hier ein sehr lustres Thema angesprochen.
Haben wir noch andere Themen?
Wir hätten zum Beispiel noch
GitHub-Stars der Woche.
Unser Klassiker.
In unserem wöchentlichen Podcast.
Jup, du bist Gast.
Hast du was Cooles mitgebracht?
Ja, aber
den XAI-Editor
und
X-Ray habt ihr ja schon
weggenommen. Ich habe noch
Inversify.js.
Das ist eine
Dependency
Injection-Bibliothek
JavaScript und TypeScript. Das ist die mit diesem
gruseligen, umgedrehten Dreieck,
was aussieht wie das Illuminaten-Zeichen.
Genau diese.
Oh, mit einem Auge drin.
Sogar mit einem Auge drin.
Was ist denn ein Dependency Injection-System?
Was macht man damit?
Also die Idee ist, wenn du
deine Software...
Also Dependency Injection ist
eine Möglichkeit, um
Inversion of Control
zu implementieren. Inversion of Control
ist, wenn ihr schon mal von den Solid-Design-Prinzipien
gehört habt, ist das I da drin.
Und
die Idee ist, dass man
nicht von konkreten Dingen
abhängt, sondern immer von,
dass Objekte nicht von konkreten Dingen abhängen sollten,
sondern immer von Abstraktionen.
Also das Schlimmste, was du machen kannst, ist, dass du bei
Vererbung in deine
Basisklasse die gesamte Logik reinpackst.
Genau.
Also die Idee ist, dass man
nicht das Sparbuch von
einem Buch erben lassen sollte,
weil es sieht zwar von außen vielleicht so aus,
aber es ist halt was Konkretes und nichts Abstraktes.
Und dass man gegen Interfaces programmieren sollte.
Wenn man jetzt sagt,
okay, alle Klassen in meiner Software
müssen von irgendeinem Interface abhängen,
da hat man irgendwie das Problem,
ja ganz viel doppelten Code
und man muss irgendwie alle diese Klassen insensuieren
und man hat dann irgendwie zu jeder konkreten Klasse,
zu jedem Interface eine konkrete Klasse oder manchmal mehrere.
Und die Frage ist jetzt, wie macht man diese Zuordnung von Interface zu konkreter Klasse?
Und das ist, dass Dependency Injection heißt,
dass die Klasseninterfaces im Konstruktor kriegen,
dass man die da rein bringt.
hat auch den Vorteil, dass wenn man
ein konstruiertes Objekt einmal hat,
dass es dann all seine
Dependencies schon mitbringt. Also,
wenn es erstmal konstruiert ist, kann es auch funktionieren.
Es hat Vorteile
gegenüber, wenn man dann noch eine Startmethode hat
und wo man was reingeben muss,
dann muss man dann, was passiert, wenn man
die zweimal callt, solche Sachen entverhindern
einfach alle Dependencies drin.
Warum braucht man jetzt
irgendeine Bibliothek dazu?
Stellt sich heraus, dass es leichter
ist,
sowas zusammenzubauen, diese Dependency-Hierarchie,
wenn man sich um die ganzen
Abhängigkeiten da drin
nicht mehr kümmern muss. Also
man kann sagen,
ich habe ein Interface
und
für dieses Interface möchte ich
die Klasse, ich habe ein Interface
Tier und für dieses
Interface möchte ich
die Implementierung Hund haben
und da kann man
Dependencies zwischen den Klassen deklarieren,
also welche Klasse welche andere im Konstruktor kriegt
und kann eine Zuordnung von Interface zu konkreter Klasse haben.
Und so eine Dependency Injection Library,
die baut dann einfach dieses gesamte Konstrukt zusammen
oder sagt dir, nee, das geht gar nicht,
weil du hast hier eine zyklische Abhängigkeit da drin.
Oder für dieses Interface, was irgendwo hier in der Klasse gebraucht wird,
da brauche ich aber jetzt noch eine Implementierung und du hast mir keine gegeben,
weil du hast es gar nicht aufgezählt.
Wofür es auch ganz toll ist, ist für Mock-Objekte.
Also wenn jetzt, wenn man sagt, man hat einen Unit-Test,
ich möchte die eine Klasse in Isolation testen,
dann kann ich sagen, okay, alle Interfaces, von denen die Klasse abhängt,
die fülle ich jetzt mit
Mock-Objekten und
man baut diese Liste zusammen und instanziert
dann die Cluster und alles drum, wo man es auch gleich mit
Mock-Objekten ist relativ einfach
und bequem. Und gerade
bei großen Dependency-Bäumen,
die man aufbaut,
ist es halt schön zu benutzen. Also man kann ziemlich schnell
einzelne Objekte, die das gleiche Interface
und Gravitieren auch damit austauschen.
Composition over Inheritance
at its best quasi.
Wolltest du mir gerade was sagen?
Ja, du warst bloß so weit weg vom Mikro,
als du einfach hast zu reden.
Der spannende Teil ist noch,
wie hinterher die Klangqualität ist,
weil ich halt gerade in dieses andere Mikro reinspreche.
Sonst muss ich mir halt noch so ein Headset besorgen.
Ja, Kilian, hast du einen Pick der Woche?
Ich habe diese Woche mal
unter anderem ein kleines Spaßbibro
gestartet.
Fand ich super witzig, gerade wenn man
in einem Slack aktiv ist und seine
Kollegen, Freunde mit
Slack-Nutzer nerven möchte.
das dockt einfach an die Slack API an,
das ist ein kleines Ruby-Skript, heißt
Slack-Typing und wenn
mich jemand anschreibt und anfängt
zu tippen, dann steht da instant,
dass ich tippe
unter dem Textfeld, um die Person aufhört
zu tippen, dann höre ich auch wieder auf zu tippen.
Hier kommt auch nie was, aber
solange die Person tippt, mache ich sie nervös,
indem ich auch tippe. Das ist ein tolles kleines
Script, fand ich super witzig.
Dieser Typ, der GitHub-User Will
das würde mich wahnsinnig machen.
dieser GitHub-User Will, der hat auch generell
spaßigen anderen Sachen,
der hat auch so ein wunderschönes kleines
Dings geschrieben.
Das haust du als
Error-Page an deine
Web-App ran und
wenn der Nutzer die
geserved bekommt, weil du, keine Ahnung,
einen Server-Error produziert hast, aus irgendeinem
Grund, dann schaut
dir einfach den User-Agent des Browsers
des Besuchers an und
rendert dem eine Seite, die aussieht wie seine
Seite, wenn er keine Internet-Verbindung hat.
und dann, das heißt glaube ich
reverse blame oder so,
user blame oder shift blame
und es tut einfach
so, als ob der Nutzer für den Fehler
verantwortlich ist, weil er keine Verbindung hat
und nicht irgendwie dein Tool,
weil es nicht gerade
einen Error rausgehauen hat.
Vielleicht hat das GitHub tatsächlich
vorhin mal live ausprobiert gehabt,
weil ich habe GitHub
aufmachen wollen und ich habe tatsächlich
einfach keine Verbindung gekriegt, obwohl ich
alle anderen Seiten aufmachen konnte
und laden konnte.
Vielleicht hatten die einfach bloß einen 503
und haben mir diese Seite dabei ausgeliefert.
Das ist
hier kurz mit, das ist von dem GitHub-User
slash will einfach noch mit drin.
Achso, du meinst das ja gerade.
Genau, ich wollte
noch ein extra, also für die Spaßkategorie
wollte ich noch einen anderen GitHub-Stuff
vergeben und zwar
git to blame someone else.
Ihr kennt ja schon git blame, da kann man
sehen, wer schuld ist, aber
es gibt übrigens auch
Es geht öfter mal, wenn ich mich über irgendwas ärgere,
kommt raus, dass ich selber war
vor zwei Jahren.
Da hilft, geht Blame Someone Else.
Da kann man den
Commit
markieren und
sagen, wem
man das wünscht, dass der den
Committed hätte und
dann schön die History
rewriten.
Großartig, sehr praktisch.
Sehr praktisch, muss man halt nur unauffällig noch
Master History Rewrite
irgendwie unterbringen und nachts bei
einem Kollegen
Forst resetten.
Ich würde sagen, dass das Tool in der Readme ganz oben
ein Zitat hat. I love Get Blame Someone
Alice von Linus Torvalds.
Mit Sternchen. Ich weiß nicht, was hinter dem Sternchen ist.
Da steht gerade unten, wenn man da erklärt, dass es fake ist.
Im Gegenteil, dazu
gibt es übrigens auch das Git Tool
Get Praise,
was quasi einfach nur ein Ersatz für Get Blame
ist, aber... Was negativ konnotiert ist?
Was negativ konnotiert ist.
Was mir mal fehlt,
was mir fehlen würde, wäre eine schöne Lösung
dafür, dass man Git-Blame
durch Formatierung kaputt macht.
Also wenn irgendwie eine
Code-Datei durch einen Format
durchgejagt wird.
Also du Whitespace-Besit was irgendwie ignorieren.
Sollte Git-Blame, ist das Git-Blame hinterher,
steht einfach bei den ganzen
einzelnen Zeilen dran, formatiert
am so und so wird und du weißt nicht mehr, ob das
nur eine alte Zeile oder eine neue Zeile ist.
Das wäre schön, wenn
meine IDE solche Formatting...
Es gibt ja
Conventional Changelog und eine bestimmte
Syntax für Changelogs.
Wenn es da zum Beispiel eine extra Syntax
für... Es gibt es, glaube ich, sogar... Es gibt ein extra
Prefix für Formatting.
Es wäre schön, wenn meine IDE
diese Format-Commits einfach rausfiltern
würde und den Blame von dem Commit
davor nehmen würde.
GitHub macht das, glaube ich, sogar schon, dass sie in
PRs, wenn du möchtest, gar keine Whitespace-Changes
anzeigen. Das wäre halt der erste Schritt
dahin. Es gibt auch bei
GitDiv auf der Kommando-Zahlung. Achso, stimmt, das kannst du ja auch
einfach das Flaggen geben. Ja, es gibt auch GitBlamen auf der Kommando-Zahlung.
Ah. Also GitBlamen mit die Gifte.
Aber kann der auch dann
diverse White-Space-Changes
zurück und zum eigentlichen
Blame-Origin kommt?
Ja, das Problem ist, glaube ich, es geht nicht für,
also es geht wirklich nur für reine White-Space-Changes,
also nur wenn jemand eine Zeile
komplett umgebrochen hat, also aber wenn jemand eine Zeile
umgebrochen und dann neu eingerückt hat, dann geht's nicht mehr.
Okay, das ist ja echt schwierig über
alle Sprachbarrieren zusammen.
Das geht natürlich komplett kaputt, wenn jemand in der Sprache
Whitebase-Code schreibt.
Oder wenn er mal
Funktionen umsortiert.
Oder Zeilen umsortiert.
Da hat Git übrigens
letztens ein Update bekommen,
dass GitDiv dir jetzt,
wenn du möchtest, in einer anderen Farbe anzeigt,
wenn einfach nur Zeilen verschoben wurden.
Und nicht einfach nur, das ist nicht da,
wurde es erleset und da wieder hinzugefügt, sondern
es wurde übrigens einfach nur nach da verschoben.
Weißt du noch, wie der Parameter hieß?
Ne.
im GitHub-Blog einfach nachschauen.
Die haben das schön dokumentiert
im GitHub-Blog, wie man das macht,
dass man das einfach dann, keine Ahnung,
blau im Diff angezeigt bekommt.
Stimmt, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Wer auch immer einen ziemlich schönen
Change-Log von Git selber
anzeigt oder zusammenfasst,
ist GitHub.
Ja, eigentlich selber mit Git
und der Entwicklung von Git nicht direkt was zu tun haben.
Ich meine, die haben da auch schon Changes reinbekommen.
Ja, natürlich arbeiten die wahrscheinlich sogar sehr aktiv
an Git mit, aber Git selber wird
soweit ich weiß nicht auf GitHub entwickelt zum Beispiel.
Sie haben eine Library-Implementierung
in LibGit 2,
die so die To-Go-Implementierung
für alle möglichen Sprachen, also
für alle möglichen Libraries in allen möglichen Sprachen,
das fällt selber an CS.
Die ganzen Reports auf GitHub
liegen ja auch nicht einfach so irgendwo in einem Filesystem
auf irgendeinem GitHub-Server rum. Die müssen da ja tatsächlich
ein bisschen schlauer rangehen in das Trick-System.
Da muss man sich einfach...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie aktuell der noch ist,
aber es gab vor Jahren mal einen sehr schönen Talk.
Das ist wieder was, also die ganzen
Show Notes für diese Folge rauszunehmen, der Horror.
Es gab einen Talk,
der hieß Making Git Perform,
wo einer von den GitHub-Ingenieuren
so ein bisschen aus dem Nähkästchen plaudert, wie sie es geschafft haben,
irgendwie das Backend-Performant
hinzukriegen, was sich eigentlich Git selber
und die Datenstruktur, die Git im Hintergrund
abbildet, nicht wirklich gut dafür eignet,
so einen Webdienst zu betreiben.
Apropos GitHub, wenn wir schon ganz kurz
dabei sind, apropos den GitHub-Blog,
was da letztens aufgetaucht hat und mein
Herz sehr, sehr, sehr geerfreut hat,
ist, dass sie jetzt, nachdem ich es mir
jahrelang gewünscht habe und sie immer wieder angeschrieben
habe, ist, dass sie TLS-Support für
GitHub-Pages mit Custom-Domains haben.
Das ist so toll.
Prompt war meine Seite und mein Blog direkt
mit einem sauberen Let's Encrypt-Certifikat.
Jetzt auch mit
TLS-Enabled, fand ich super cool.
Okay, du musst dich nicht mal mehr selber drum kümmern.
Nee, du musst einfach nur sagen, ich hätte gerne
eins und bam, das war's.
Nee, du musst dir niemals selbst das.
Wieso muss ich das sagen?
Du musst nur sagen, wenn du
eine Apex-Domain, also
Kira.io, auf der
GitHub-Page zeigst, dann musst du die
IPs updaten und für
alles, was ein CNAME direkt nutzt
im DMS, das läuft einfach schon
über TLS jetzt. Das haben sie für dich
in der Zinküpfung. Nee, ich glaube, du musst es einmal rausnehmen
und wieder hinzufügen. Dann triggern sie das und
machen es demnächst einfach für alle. Du kannst noch
den Haken setzen in der
GitHub-Repo-UI
von wegen Enforce-HTPS.
dass er auch nur das geht und er auch weiterleitet.
Aber hat auch für GitHub-Tips den Vorteil,
wenn du das machst, dass sie das
über den CDN gut clashen können
und die GitHub-Pages dann performanter
wohl ausliefern. Aber so oder so finde ich
es sehr, sehr cool. Lange gewünscht
und die hatten es nur für die Custom-GitHub.io
nicht Custom-Domains
schon immer drin.
Seit 2000, keine Ahnung wann.
11 oder so?
Nee.
16? 16.
Realistisch.
Ich hatte gerade noch so eine Erinnerung an meinen Entwicklungsflow als Teenager,
als ich angefangen habe mit Programmieren,
habe ich tatsächlich angefangen, PHP zu schreiben und damit Web-Anwendungen zu bauen.
Ein Blog, ein Gästebuch, ein kleines eigenes CMS.
Und der Entwicklungsflow war, du schreibst ein Boto, lädst über FDP hoch,
auf Live.
Na klar.
Und dann testest du dort.
Es wäre eigentlich cool, wenn diese ganzen
LAMP-Anbieter einfach
damals schon anstatt
FDP
heißt doch FDP.
Ja, File Turn-to-Protokoll.
Das habe ich schon zu lange nicht mehr benutzt.
Ja, SFTP lebt auch noch.
Wenn die damals einfach statt FDP
Git angeboten hätten, weil dann hätte ich vielleicht meine Änderung
auch mal wieder ruhig eigentlich machen können.
Hast du mal noch die alten Webseiten
angeguckt in der Wayback-Maschine?
Wir können
nachher nochmal in Ruhe auf
Hendrik-Sollich.de.vU
gehen.
Ich habe ja schon mal die Geschichte
im Podcast erzählt, dass
ich auf MSN
auf der Suchmaschine
sogar eine handgeschriebene
Rezension zu meiner Seite
gefunden habe, als ich mich selbst gesucht habe.
Ich bin, glaube ich,
mal dran mit einem Pick.
Und zwar was, was mir heute erst vor die
Flinte gelaufen ist. Ich habe es erst mal
in unserem Firmen-Slack
geteilt und ich weiß allerdings nicht, ob es
wirklich jemand will, aber ich fand es witzig.
Und zwar heißt das
Sudo-Pair. Und zwar, und das
war mir gar nicht bewusst, kann man für Sudo-Plugins
schreiben. Und Sudo-Pair
macht folgendes, wenn du Sudo eingibst,
dann kriegst du erstmal den Hinweis, wie normal
bei Sudo, dass du übrigens jetzt bitte
vorsichtig sein sollst und dass du mit der
Verantwortung, die dir Sudo
überträgt,
ordentlich umgehen sollst.
Was Sudo-Pair jetzt stattdessen allerdings macht,
anstatt dass es dir einfach, sobald du dich eingeloggt hast
mit deinen Benutzer Credentials,
die ja Root-Rechte für den nächsten Befehl gibt,
ist, dass es dir ein Stück Code ausspuckt,
was du dann bitte auf einem Kanal
einem anderen Mitarbeiter
aus einer bestimmten Gruppe überreißt.
Der muss das dann bei sich
auf der gleichen Kiste in der Shell eingeben
oder es wird direkt ein SSH-Kommando,
dass der das irgendwo eintippen kann
und wird auf der gleichen Kiste verbunden.
Der sieht dann, dass du dort gerade
Sudo eingegeben hast,
muss das absegnen
und sieht dann über eine live
Tmux-Session oder
Tmux-artige Session, was du dann
mit diesem Sudo machst.
Was einfach super witzig ist,
wenn dann wahrscheinlich, ist es sogar interessant, wenn du
auf irgendwelchen Roots-Servern
irgendwelche Skripte oder Zertifikate
erinnerst, dass da
immer noch ein zweiter mit drauf gucken muss,
wenn du da was mit Sudo machst.
Sudo-Pair.
Nämlich ein bisschen dieses Feature von iOS,
wo Kinder mit
Kinder-Apple-IDs im App-Store
nicht den Purchase-Button
haben, sondern quasi einen Ask-to-Purchase-Button.
Wenn die da draufklicken, kriegen die Eltern eine Push-Notification
mit der Zahlung und können die bestätigen oder
den einen.
Wenn der Vater gerade auf dem Sofa eingeschlafen ist, halten die Kinder
natürlich einfach das iPhone an den Daumen.
Der Daumen ist frei. Das ist Authentication.
Authentication Digit.
Ich habe mich immer gefragt, wofür
Passcodes in Kindles
gut sind, bis ich neulich mal
irgendwie so eine 50
Dollar Kindle-Rechnung
gekriegt habe und mein Kindle auf die
maximale Schriftgröße eingestellt
war, als ich ihn gefunden habe und ich dann
irgendwie herausgefunden habe, dass meine Tochter
irgendwie da drauf ein Bild rumgeklickt
hat, aber das kann man alles zurückgeben.
Dass man ein Bild eingekauft
hat im Amazon Store.
Bei Kindle kauft
man erstaunlich schnell ein Buch. Ich habe
als den ersten Kindle bei uns in der Familie
gab es, der auf der Geburtstagsfeier dann mal
im Kreis gegangen und als er einmal
wieder zurückgekommen ist, waren zwei neue
Hüfte drauf.
Das war ein schönes
YouTube-Video, als die Apple Watch
rauskam und es erst mal
von jedem anderen wieder so eine dumme Apple Watch App gab,
die überhaupt nicht sinnvoll war
und da hat jemand in so einer Bar so gedemot
und so, ja, schau mal, hier gibt es diese Amazon-App,
da kann ich bloß vorher auch suchen, da ist so ein Xbox One
gesucht und so und da muss ich bloß vorsichtig, wenn ich
auf diesen großen grünen Knopf drücke, dann ist die Instinkt kauft
und dann scrollt er so, aber dank des Lags der Apple Watch
da so drauf und nein, du hast direkt
Xbox bestellt.
Na klar, kannst du einfach die Order
wieder canceln, aber Amazon
ist ja auch super kulant. Zum einen zum Bestellen
von physischen Sachen, aber auch digital.
Wenn der
nicht mehr verschickt wurde, muss man schnell
das noch canceln. Alexa,
kauf mir ein Puppenhaus.
Für drei Tonnen
Katzenfutter.
Alexa, bestell mir drei Tonnen
Ich habe letztens auf Amazon
zufällig eine Empfehlung bekommen, als ich
die Artikelseite von einem Buch offen hatte,
ob ich nicht, ich bin mir
immer noch sicher, dass ich mich geirrt habe, aber
das war die Anzeige da,
ob ich nicht für diesen Artikel einen
Dashbutton haben möchte.
Für ein Buch.
Was mache ich denn mit dem Dashbutton für ein Buch?
Wenn ich es gelesen habe, drücke ich drauf und kriege ich dasselbe nochmal, oder was?
Vielleicht ist es eine Serie.
Das war total unendlich.
Ich habe aber lange Zeit diese Dashbuttons echt für
den April-Sherz gehalten.
Ich habe auch lange gebraucht, bis ich das gecheckt habe.
Ja, aber diese Recommendations,
die funktionieren nie.
Oh, ich habe ein Gateboard gekauft.
Ja, willst du noch drei?
Nee, nee.
Ich habe einen Staubsauger gekauft.
Vielleicht wären die passenden Staubsaugerbeutel
eine gute Empfehlung,
aber nein, willst du nicht noch einen Staubsauger?
Sowieso.
Oh Mann, da
fehlt noch einiges an
Cleverei-Ei, um die Dinger ein bisschen aufzubohren.
Also wahrscheinlich einfach, weil die Leute
fünf Staubsauger bestellen
und dann viel zurückschicken,
wo ihnen die Farbe...
Vielleicht machen das einfach so viele Leute
und die machen uns anderen allen einfach die
Recommendation Endless kaputt. Vielleicht ist es genau das.
Also ich glaube, meine Oma war
ab einem gewissen Punkt bei QVC
gesperrt, weil sie
einfach ganz viel Hosen und
Händen in unterschiedlichen,
drei, vier unterschiedlichen Größen bestellt hat
und das zurückgeschickt hat.
Obwohl das bei manchen Shops ist, das ist ja wirklich
echt okay. Also bei Thomann,
was ja so ein Musikinstrument der Händler
ist das überhaupt kein Problem,
wenn du da drei Gitarren bestellst und zwei wieder
zurückschickst. Das ist immer eine Frage.
Es gibt ja gewisse Sachen, die musst du einfach physisch
ausprobieren. Es gibt Sachen, die kann man
danach nicht mehr benutzen.
Es gibt gewisse Produkte, die würde ich nicht
zurückschicken lassen.
Hosen wären ehrlich gesagt mit dabei,
weil du kannst ja auch nicht zum gleichen
Wert die zurückgeschickten Hosen
nochmal verkaufen. Soweit ich weiß, hat Amazon
irgendwie in den eigenen Markt, dass Sachen, die zurückgeschickt werden,
einfach gar nicht direkt bei Amazon ankommen,
sondern direkt bei irgendwelchen Zweitverwertern landen,
die das dann weiterverkaufen, als gebraucht war.
Sobald du die Originalverpackung geöffnet hast,
ist es ja quasi nicht mehr wiederverkaufbar bei vielen Produkten.
Interessant, wer weiß.
Das ist auch so eine Sache, die Amazon sehr unbeliebt gemacht hat
bei irgendwelchen Leuten, die im Amazon Store oder im Amazon Market verkaufen wollten,
dass Amazon Produkte
immer hat zurückschicken lassen
und die teilweise aber bei dem Originalhändler gar nicht wieder angekommen sind.
Und dass Amazon die quasi selber
zurückgekauft hat.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die genaue Geschichte
dahinter war.
Dubioser Serpens.
Du machst gerade deine alte Seite
in der Wayback Machine auf.
Was suchst du?
Das sind die Aftershow-Party.
Zeigen wir uns alle unsere Homepages aus den frühen
2000er.
Oh ja.
Einen GitHub-Star habe ich noch.
Ich habe seit einem Monat
nutze ich das jetzt aktiv und wünsche da eigentlich,
ich hätte das schon viel, viel früher schon angefangen.
Seit Jahren eigentlich.
Ein tolles Programm im Anki
ist in Python geschrieben mit
Qt Frontend. Das ist nur am Rande.
Die Idee dahinter ist,
du willst die Dinge
merken. Egal was für eine Form
von Information.
Und das ist bei deinem Gehirn natürlich
immer so eine Sache. Wann kannst du dich daran erinnern?
das meiste verlierst du sowieso wieder raus, relativ schnell.
Aber da haben sich Space Repetition Systems
vor einer Weile durchgesetzt als
das State-of-the-Art-Möglichkeit, um Dinge wirklich
in deinen Kopf reinzuhämmern.
Und da hat Anki
die Logik umgesetzt, ich glaube von der Software
mit Super-Memo von Uhrzeiten,
die dich einfach in regelmäßigen
Zeitabständen immer wieder an Informationen
erinnert und dich dazu bringt, dich selber
versuchen, die zu recallen.
Dass du halt versuchst, dich selber dran zu erinnern und dann halt
Anki sagst, ob du das halt geschafft hast oder nicht.
also so eine Art Flashcard
Tool ist das dann, worauf das hinausläuft
und der Space, die dann, wenn du
richtig beantwortet hast, in immer größeren
Zeitabständen und fragt dich immer
später nochmal, die Idee ist,
dass du halt immer genau an dieser Grenze des Vergessens
bleibst, wo du dich gerade so
diese Information, dieses Wissen
wieder vergisst und dann
daran erinnert wirst und somit hältst du das
am ehesten in deinem Kopf mit drin
und ich nutze das jetzt seit einem Monat
sehr aktiv, um
wirklich alles Mögliche
im Kopf zu behalten. Ich habe angefangen damit,
als ich versucht habe, jetzt eine Sprache zu lernen,
in meinem Fall Mandarin,
aber habe da jetzt auch angefangen, mich sehr aktiv
mit der Software auseinandersetzen, auch mit der Community drumherum
und was die so alles da rein speichern,
ob das jetzt wirklich
Wissen ist, was ich einfach mal wissen wollte,
wie zum Beispiel, was
die Straßenbahn-Signale
auf Ampeln, die Straßenbahn-Ampeln
so bedeuten haben, oder ob das jetzt
persönliche Details sind, zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung.
das fällt mir natürlich kein Beispiel ein
Steigers Lieblingstorte ist Donauwelle
Lieblingskuchen ist Donauwelle
Kehens Geburtstag
Okay, Geburtstag, dafür ist mein Kalender da
die brauche ich nicht im Kopf haben, aber zumindest kannst du
so Erinnerungen nicht zu etwas machen
was halt mal passiert und mal nicht
oder zu einer Sache machen, die du halt
das wird halt so eine Choice
ich möchte mich daran erinnern und dann vergesse ich das auch
nie wieder und darum kümmert sich Anki halt
das ist eine fantastische Software, gibt es auch
für Mobilgeräte von dem
eigentliche Maintainer selber ist auch die iOS-App.
Der finanziert leider seinen Unterhalt
mit der iOS-App, deswegen ist es eine relativ teure
iOS-App mit 25 Euro.
Die Android-App ist nicht von
ihm, sondern von anderen, die ist aber dann free.
Aber es ist eine echt tolle Software.
Ich finde es auch auf iOS
große Klasse, sehr gelungen.
Und nutzt, wie gesagt, seit einem Monat jetzt.
Und habe damit schon echt ganz gute Erfolge mit
allen möglichen Kramen. Finde ich
echt cool. Gefällt mir.
Ich würde mir sehr...
Super gut.
Wie fließend ist dein Mandarinen bis jetzt?
Ich gehe es sehr, sehr langsam an.
Ich möchte es nicht
hier jetzt dämonen, weil meine Aussprache noch für
eine Arsch ist.
Da steckt noch ein bisschen mehr an Arbeit.
Jetzt ist die jüdendfreie Folge vorbei.
Das wäre jetzt die Gelegenheit,
den akronomisierbar
in den chinesischen
Markt auszuweiten. Genau, dann
begrüße ich alle mal herzlich.
Nicht mal herzlich, ich begrüße alle mal und sage wieder
Tschüss und frage, wie sie heißen
und 10 bis 10
und frage, ob es die Studenten sind
und was die essen.
Oder nicht.
Chinesisch, aber Mandarin,
quasi, ich sage mal Chinesisch einfach mal,
ist eine recht witzige Sprache.
Die Grammatik ist super easy.
Du reißt einfach quasi nur die Wörter aneinander,
die du sagen möchtest.
Und der Satz ergibt sich einfach daraus schon.
Wenn du so ein Fragewort an das Ende erhängst,
dann wird das Ganze nur so eine Frage.
Hat ein paar witzige Sachen,
wie du kannst du nicht sagen, ich esse.
Das ist einfach grammatikalisch nicht okay.
du musst sagen, was du isst. Und damit
du einfach sagen kannst, ich esse,
hat sich so eine Art Default-Speise entwickelt. Und was
soll das andere sein als, ich esse Reis?
Das heißt, ich esse Reis bedeutet so viel wie
ich esse und nicht ich explizit
ich esse Reis. Finde ich super witzig,
dass da solche Sachen drin sind.
Und was sagst du, wenn du Reis essen möchtest?
Das weiß ich noch nicht.
Vielleicht musst du es dann betonen. Wir haben ja auch
sehr viele Arten, Wörter einzeln zu betonen,
was sehr interessant ist.
Da steige ich auch noch nicht ganz dahinter.
Diese fünf Töne sind auch relativ gut
definiert, aber die
rauszuhören ist manchmal echt nicht gar so trivial.
Es gibt auch so ein altes chinesisches Gedicht,
was wohl nur aus dem unterschiedlichen
Beton des Lautes
irgendwie
in die Richtung läuft. Es geht halt irgendwie um einen Löwen,
der irgendwie so ein Typen ist.
Das ist so ein ewig langer Text.
Und das ist nur, wenn du es liest in
Pinyin, also in der
lateinischen Schriftzeichen
überdrückend, dann steht ja nur
S-H-I-S-H-I-S-H-I-S-H-I-S-H-I-S-H-I-S-
Die Bedeutung ist halt nur über die Betonungsarten
steckt da komplett drin, aber da ist halt
ein kompletter Text dahinter.
Das ist krass.
Wenn du es auf lateinische Zeichen und auf
westliche Aussprache
abbildest, hast du einen unwahrscheinlichen
Informationsverlust bei China.
Die Schrift, da gibt es
tatsächlich das Pinion dafür,
um das abzubilden, aber du darfst halt nicht
auf unsere Aussprache
mit Rubemetschen, da verlierst du halt alles.
Also wenn du in Dresden in der
Budapester Straße mal an dem Wohnheim standest,
da war irgendwie die Namensliste im Eingangsbereich,
da waren halt auch sehr viele Chinesen
untergebracht und die
hießen halt alle XU.
Alle, oder fast alle,
also mindestens 20 Leute dort hießen XU,
danach gab es eine ganze Menge
XI und Xing, aber die hießen garantiert
alle komplett unterschiedlich und
unterschiedlich ausgesprochen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das liegt eher daran, dass du
auf unsere Zechen abbilden.
Ich glaube, das liegt eher daran, dass du in dem Raum
eher den Nachnamen vor dem
Vornamen hinpackst.
also wie im Bayerischen,
das Bayerisch, das Chinesisch des
deutschen Raums, dass du den
Nachnamen zuerst sagst und da sind halt dann
gewisse statistische
Häufungen nicht unwahrscheinlich.
Ich kenne persönlich einen Chinesen, der
auch Xu heißt
und witzigerweise heißt seine Frau,
der Mädchenname seiner Frau ist auch
Xu, zumindest
wenn er es so liest, aber es ist halt ein komplett anderer Name
und es spricht sich auch komplett anders aus.
In Chinesisch würde es sich auch komplett anders schreiben.
Die Sprache hat noch ein paar andere witzige Features,
vielleicht gerade noch im Kopf hatte, das war von so einem
witzigen Video von so einer Frau, die
den Ted Talk gehalten hat, ich habe ihren Namen leider vergessen,
aber Chinesi heißt das Ganze, der hat sie
geschartet als Konzept, um für einfaches
Chinese beizubringen
und die hatte so ein paar witzige Features, was man
sich so merken kann. Als ich das mit dem Kopf
behalten habe, erstmal ist
dieses sexistische Konzept
davon, dass das Wort für Frau,
das Zeichen für Frau ist das Zeichen
für Frau, zwei Frauen
ist das Zeichen für Streit
und drei Frauen ist das Zeichen für Ehebruch.
Fuck.
Was soll das denn?
Warum?
Aber okay, toll. Das ist der fester Teil der Sprache.
Naja, wenn es zwei Frauen gibt,
ist es immer Streit.
Ja, aber ich meine, das muss man ja...
In diesem Sinne.
In diesem Sinne rappen wir es ab.
Das war Folge 18
von Akonomisierbar.
Diesmal
wieder mal mit Jupp.
Es war uns allen eine helle Freude.
Schön, dass du mit dabei warst.
Das war großartig. Gerne.
Und der nächste Podcast
in eurer Podcast-App beginnt in
3, 2, 1.
Bui-Bi.
Großartig.
I'm pressing the spacebar
I am pressing the spacebar
And nothing is happening
This computer is about a year old
And it was very expensive
I have been waiting to upgrade for a long
time
and now you're telling me
that it would need extensive
surgery
for a speck of dust
lodged beneath the butterfly
I found
your instructions
they were not helpful
I bought this
can of air
I feel like an idiot
cause I'm pressing the spacebar
I'm pressing
the space bar. I am pressing the space bar. I'm pressing the space bar and nothing is happening.
Oh, nothing is happening. I'm pressing the space bar and nothing's happening. Get me out of here.